ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS
BATES WELL ORIGINS BRADFORD
CABALLERO CHIANG DALLY DODD THE
ROSTER GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROWTH HERTZBERG HILL HUESO-
TADO JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIREMITCHELL MONNING
MORLOCK AROUND. NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO ROCK RUBIO SKINNER
EARN NUMBER BY KOWSKI WIENER
WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GAS BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL
BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS MORNING
BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WE WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. BY CENTER MONNING.
LET US BE CENTERED IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. I PART OF YOUR WORK
WHEN I READ THIS POEM BY DENISE
LEVERTOV CALLED THE GIFT. JUST
WHEN YOU SEEM TO YOURSELF
NOTHING BUT A FLIMSY WEB OF
QUESTIONS. YOU ARE GIVEN THE
QUESTIONS OF OTHERS TO HOLD.
AND THE EMPTINESS OF YOUR HANDS.
SONGBIRD EGGS BUT CAN STILL
HATCH IF YOU KEEP THEM WARM.
BUTTERFLIES OPENING AND CLOSING
THEMSELVES IN YOUR CUPPED PALMS
RESTING YOU NOT TO INJURE THEIR
SON TO LOANS FOR THEIR DUST.
YOU ARE GIVEN THE QUESTIONS OF
OTHERS AS IF THERE WERE ANSWERS
TO ALL YOU ASK. YES PERHAPS
THIS GIFT IS YOUR ANSWER. GOD
OF LOVE AND MERCY THANK YOU FOR
GIFTING US WITH THE FREEDOM TO
WRESTLE WITH THE QUESTIONS OF
OUR DAY. AS WE DISCERN HOW BST
TO MEET THE DEEPEST NEEDS OF
ALL YOUR PEOPLE. MAY WE DO SO
FROM A STANCE OF HUMILITY. AND
A WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE THE
CREATIVITY OF ALL FOR THE
COMMON GOOD. WE ASK THIS IN
YOUR NAME AMEN. MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE TO OUR
FLAG I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. SIX AND- THIS WILL YEAH
ALL. CENTER HERTZBERG THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN THE MADDIE
LOUNGE THANK YOU. VERY GOOD
MADAM MADAM YOUR RESIDENT. ON
REPUBLICANS WILL BE CAUCUSING
AS WELL IN THE COFFEE LOUNGE
VERY GOOD THERE WILL BE A
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS AND A
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
SENATORS WE ARE
READY TO BEGIN. THE SET THE
SENATE WILL. BECAUSE CALL TO
ORDER WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE
GOING TO MEET MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DEBT OF
THE DAILY FILE. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SENATOR WHITE HOUSE KEY
ARE YOU READY. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI AN ACT RELATING TO
RECYCLING CENTER AYE CASKEY THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- SB THREE SEVENTY TWO
IS A COMPREHENSIVE BOTTLE BILL
REFORM THAT HAS BEEN TALKED
ABOUT FOR YEARS LITERALLY YEARS
WITH THE BROWN ADMINISTRATION
AND NOW THE NEWS MINISTRATION
AND FINALLY. FINALLY FIXES
CALVET FOR MUSIC ANTIQUATED
BEVERAGE CONTAINER REDEMPTION
RECYCLING PROGRAM WHEN EXTEND
THE PRODUCER RESPONSIBLE THE
PROGRAM COLLEAGUES AS YOU KNOW
OTHER STATES OFTEN LOOK TO
CALIFORNIA'S THE LEADER ON
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES HOWEVER
THEY DO NOT LOOK TO US FOR
LEADERSHIP ON RECYCLING
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS IN FACT
THEY DO EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
NOT EMULATE OUR PROGRAM. AFTER
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS AND
SEVENTY FIVE BILLS LATER THE
BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM NO LONGER
REFLECTS THE NEEDS NO LONGER
REFLECTS CAPABILITIES AND NO
LONGER REFLECTS THE
TECHNOLOGIES AVAILABLE TO
EXERCISE THESE VALUABLE
RESOURCES WHILE CUTTING WAYS
THIS BILL BEFORE YOU SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO IS THE CULMINATION
OF MANY YEARS OF EFFORTS I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON IT FOR FOUR
YEARS FIFTEEN JURISDICTIONS
AROUND THE WORLD HAVE EXTENDED
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
PROGRAMS FOR THEIR BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS. IT'S BASED ON
FORMER GOVERNOR BROWN SAID
EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY DID NOT
RESULT IN A BILL AN
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY OVERSIGHT
HEARING TO TRY CHAIRED A COUPLE
YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE REPORT CAL.
ONLY PAPER FROM A COUPLE YEARS
AGO FROM NINETEEN OUR. TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AS WELL AS IT
YOUR- RE. AND BY IN ME I HAVE A
COPY HERE A THE CAL BEVERAGE
CONTAINER PROGRAM THIS
ORGANIZATION WROTE THE RULES IN
THE IN THE E. U. ON THEIR E. P.
R. PROGRAM. IT'S BASED ON
EXHAUSTED MEETINGS WITH KEY
STAKEHOLDERS AND I'M HERE TO
REPRESENT THAT THIS BILL IS IF
THE THIS BILL SUCCESSFUL TODAY
IN GETS OFF THE FLOOR THOSE
EXHAUSTIVE MEETINGS WILL
CONTINUE EVERYBODY IS GOING TO
BE AT THE TABLE IN SORT OF
INFORMING. IN A CREATING A
PROGRAM THAT'S GOING TO WORK.
VISITS AND MANY CONVERSATIONS
WITH MEMBERS OF FROM OREGON THE
BRITISH COLUMBIA IN NORWAY
OFFICIALS WHO WERE RUNNING MUCH
MORE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS AND WE
ARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
BILL EMBRACES FOUR MAJOR
PRINCIPLES AND IT'S A
COMPREHENSIVE AND COST SAVING
SOLUTION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FIRST. ITS GOAL IS
TO IMPROVE RECYCLING IN
REMANUFACTURING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SECOND IT SHARED
RESPONSE RESPONSIBILITIES NOT
ONE. ONE ENTITY SECOND IT
ENHANCES ADAPTABILITY INSISTING
ABILITIES. AND FOURTH IT HAS NO
CARVE OUTS THAT'S RIGHT WHOEVER
IS PART OF THE PROBLEM MUST BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION. NOW OUR
CURRENT BOTTLE BILL IN
CALIFORNIA COST OVER FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY JUST
IN THE MINISTRATION WHAT CAL
RECYCLE I KNOW SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE
THAT. OUR WOULD LOOK FOR A
LEANER GOVERNMENT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY IN SB THREE TWENTY
TWO TO SUPPORT- THE KNOWLEDGE
ME THAT WE HAVE A BROKEN BOTTLE
PROGRAM AND WE'RE GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO PRIVATE INDUSTRY. TO
RUN. AND SB THREE SEVENTY TWO
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS BY
REMOVING THE REDEMPTION AND
RECYCLING ADMINISTRATIVE
RESPONSIBILITIES TO THIS NEW
PRIVATELY RUN THE STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAM IT'S TIME TO CANDACE
PROGRAM IN ITS CURRENT FORM AND
START FRESH THE SP THREE
SEVENTY TWO DOES THE FOLLOWING
IT CREATES A DISTRIBUTOR
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM THAT
DISTRIBUTORS SHORTS A PROGRAM
I'VE SEEN THE LETTERS IT
INCLUDES THE MANUFACTURES
INCLUDES THIS TRIGGERS INCLUDES
TO RETAIL OUTLETS IT INVOLVES
ALL STAKEHOLDERS IT EXPANDS
THIS PROGRAM TO INCLUDE WINE
AND DISTILLED. SPIRITS THIS IS
A LONG DISCUSS AN OVERDUE
MEASURE TO INCLUDE THE NINE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION BOTTLES THAT CONSUMERS
ARE CONSTITUENTS MISS OUT ON
BEER IS ALREADY IN AND LET'S
FINALLY STEP UP TO THE WINE
INDUSTRY TO MAKE THEM BE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDS THEY
CLAIM TO BE I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL THE MEMBERS IN
THOSE OPPOSITION LETTERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY COME
TOGETHER IN A COHESIVE WAY SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO WILL PUTS
GOVERNMENT'S ROLE THIS IS CAL
RECYCLES ROLE BUT THIS NOT.
LIMITED ITS RESPONSIBILITY IT
REQUIRED CAL RECYCLE TO
ESTABLISH A MINIMUM CONTENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR BOTTLES SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO LET THE
EXPERTS TO THE JOBS THAT IS IT
LET'S BUSINESSES MAKE MORE TERM
TO SEE THAT WILL BENEFIT THEIR
COST. WE PUT. EVERYBODY IS.
THERE'S CARVE OUTS SPEAK PLAY
ON THE SAME PLAYING FIELD AND
THIS THE STATE DOES WHAT IS
SUPPOSED TO DO IT SAID SCHOOLS
AND OVERSEES THE PROGRAMS THE
STAKEHOLDERS KNOW THEIR
INDUSTRY BASS SO IF THEY JOIN
THE PCS SO PROCESS IT WORK IT
OUT AND THEY COME TO THE GREEN
MAN AND A PLAN THE- THE BILL IN
IN PRINT RIGHT NOW PUTS A STARK
DATED JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TO GIVE THIS PROCESS OF
THE NAP TIME. WE HAVE A CHOICE
TODAY MEMBERS. WE CAN CONTINUE
TO SUCCUMB TO THE WELL HEELED A
SPECIAL INTERESTS AND DO
NOTHING AND LET A FAILED
PROGRAM CONTINUE TO FAIL. WE
CAN CONTINUE A SYSTEM WHERE THE
WINE INDUSTRY CURBSIDE WASTE
HAULERS AND DISTRIBUTORS
CONTINUE THEIR STREAK RECEIVED
SPECIAL FAVORS FROM US AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE CONSUMERS. OR WE
CAN FINALLY PUT CONSUMERS FIRST
THE CONSUMERS ARE OUR
CONSTITUENTS WE CAN FINALLY
CREATE A SYSTEM THAT PUTS MONEY
BACK INTO THE HANDS OF THOSE
THAT DESERVE IT. OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO DAY IF A
CONSTITUENT CONFINED RECYCLING
CENTER THAT IS OPEN THAT WILL
TAKE BACK THEIR NICKEL BOTTLE
THAT THEY PAY FOR THEY WILL GET
TWO POINT THREE FIVE CENTS LESS
THAN HALF OF WHAT THEY PAID.
COLLEAGUES THERE'S BEEN SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT REDEMPTION
CENTERS LET ME LEAVE YOU WITH
ONE FINAL THOUGHT. OR AGAIN
WHICH HAS A SIMILAR PROGRAM IS
BEING PROPOSED IN THEIR SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO HAS ONE TENTH
OF OUR POPULATION BUT OVER
TWICE AS MANY CONSUMER
REDEMPTION POINTS. IN
CALIFORNIA HAS. WHAT WE WELL WE
SEEM TO BE CLOSER RETENTION
CENTERS MONTHLY ORGAN IS MAKING
EXPANSION PLANS. SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO IS A COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION A LONG TERM SOLUTION
TO A VERY COMPLEX PROBLEM BUT
IT'S TIME THAT WE FINALLY TAKE
ACTIONS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENATOR SKINNER. THANK
YOU AYE MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I STAND IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL-
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH- I WAS
PART OF A GROUP OF PEOPLE
WITHIN THE CITY OF BERKLEY THAT
WROTE THE VERY FIRST TO SEE
THAT STEP WAS THE FIFTY CENT
RECYCLING GOAL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE WHOLE U. S.
ACTUALLY WAS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO. AND OF COURSE AT THAT
POINT AND ARE SUBSEQUENTLY
CALIFORNIA WITH A. B. NINE
THIRTY NINE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE SEC SUCH A GOAL AND THEN
IS SINCE HAS SAID EVEN HIGHER
NOW OVER THAT TIME PERIOD IN
THE EARLY EIGHTIES THERE WERE
STILL LOTS OF FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THAT TOOK THE MATERIALS
THAT WE PUT IN A RECYCLING BIN
AND REPRODUCE THEM INTO ANOTHER
PRODUCT. THAT AND SO WELL
CERTAINLY WE SOLD A LOT OF OUR
MATERIALS TO OTHER COUNTRIES.
THERE WAS STILL A BIG MARKET
HERE. THAT MARKET IS PRETTY
MUCH GONE. SO WE'RE NOW ALMOST
ENTIRELY DEPENDENT ON SELLING
PRIMARILY TO ASIA BUT ASIA HAS
NOW TOLD US CHINA SPECIFICALLY
INDIA OTHERS. THEY DON'T WANT
THAT STUFF ANYMORE THEY'RE
PRODUCING ENOUGH OF OUR OWN. SO
WHAT WE ARE FACING IN
CALIFORNIA AND IF YOU TALK TO
EVERY HOLLER EVERY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EVERY RECYCLER WE
ARE FACING A CRISIS. NOW THIS
BILL. BY INCLUDING. GLASS
CONTAINERS IN R. C. R. V. IS A
VERY IMPORTANT STEP IT IS NOT
THE ONLY THAT WILL SOLVE THIS
CRISIS BUT IT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ONE TO HELP US AND
GIVE US THE TOOLS NUMBER ONE
GLASS IS ONE OF THE HIGHEST.
QUALITY MATERIALS TO BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE INTO ANOTHER PRODUCT.
SECONDLY IT IS OUR WINE AND
LIQUOR THAT ARE DOMINANTLY NOW
IN GLASS MANY OF THE OTHER
BEVERAGES THAT USED TO BE IN
GLASS OR NO LONGER. HOWEVER ONE
IN LIQUOR STILL TENDS TO BE IN
GLASS. NOW WHAT WE HAVE GOOD
QUOTE UNQUOTE RECYCLING RATES
OF WINE IN CALIFORNIA. THAT
MEANS 70% THAT MEANS WE HAVE
GOOD RATES OF PEOPLE PUTTING
THE WINE BOTTLE IN THE BLUE BIN.
THAT'S GOOD BUT BECAUSE IT IS
NOT IN OUR BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM
IN OUR C. R. V. PROGRAM WE ARE
NOT COLLECTING THE FUNDS THAT
HELP US HE FOR THE REST OF
RECYCLING RECYCLING IS NOT JUST
PICKING UP A PRODUCT AND SO THE
BENEFIT OF THE CHANGES THAT
THIS BILL IS ADVOCATING AND
WOULD PUT INTO PLACE IS THAT IT
WOULD HELP GIVE US ADDITIONAL
TOOLS TO ADDRESS THESE MARKET
FAILURES WERE EXPERIENCING NOW.
HOPEFULLY TO INCENTIVIZE MORE
PRODUCERS IN COUNTRY IN IN
STATE OF GLASS. SECONDARY CLASS.
END GIVE US SOME OF THE FUNDING
TO DO THAT. AS WELL AS-
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
REDEMPTION FACILITIES THROUGH
TO THE FINDING AND THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT THE BILL
INCLUDES SO WITH THAT I DRIVE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SAYING
NINE CENTER AYE COKIE MAY
CONCLUDE. I THINK THE INSULTS
TO THE BODY MADAM PRESIDENT NOW
WITH- REQUEST AN AYE VOTE SO WE
CAN CONTINUE THIS DISCUSSION ON
THE VERY IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL MATTER FACING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
WORLD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. ATKINS AYE BATES.
WELL I FOR JUST. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. CHIANG DALLY NO DODD
NO DORADO I GALGIANI NO GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE
HILL. HUESO I TADO I JACKSON
AYE JONES NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I MORE
LOCK. ZERO NO NIELSEN NO HAN.
PORTANTINO ROTH I RUBIO.
SKINNER HI I STERN HI I'M BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER AYE
WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN ARCHULETA. BATES
FOR JUST. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CHIANG GLAZER. GROWTH HELLO.
MCGUIRE MORE LOCK NO PAN.
PORTANTINO RUBIO. I'M BURKE.
WILK PLEASE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. BATES GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. CHIANG
GLAZER GROWTH. HILL MCGUIRE.
PAN PORTANTINO. RUBIO I'M BURKE.
WILK. SENATOR RICK OWSKI MOVES
THE CALL. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN SENATOR WIENER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIFTY BY SENATOR WIENER AN
ACT RELATING TO HOUSING SENATOR
READER THE FLOOR IS YOURS I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT BACH COLLEAGUES TODAY
AFTER TWO YEARS OF PROCESS- IN
THIS BODY SENATE BILL FIFTY IS
BEFORE US. SB FIFTY IS A
THOUGHTFUL MEANINGFUL. AND
SERIOUS AFTER TO CHIP AWAY AND
ULTIMATELY TO HELP SOLVE.
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS OUR
HOUSING SHORTAGE. SB FIFTY IS
THE PRODUCT OF TWO YEARS OF
DELIBERATION AT THE COMMITTEE
LEVEL IN THIS BODY. PLUS
MASSIVE STAKEHOLDER OUT REACHES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. SB FIFTY
IMPACT CONTAINS MANY PROVISIONS
RESULTING DIRECTLY FROM NOT
STAKEHOLDER OUT REACH. THIS
BILL ALTHOUGH IT'S TEHNICAL IN
MANY WAYS ABOUT ZONING AND
DENSITY AND HIGHLY AND SO FORTH.
FUNDAMENTALLY THIS BILL AND OUR
HOUSING WORK IN GENERAL IS IN
TALKS ABOUT THE TECHNICAL TERMS
IT IS ABOUT REAL PEOPLE AND THE
REAL PAIN THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE SUFFERING
RIGHT NOW THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
THE REAL PAIN OF CHILDREN WHO
GO AWAY TO COLLEGE AND CAN'T
MOVE BACK HOME TO THE COMMUNITY
WHERE THEY GREW UP BECAUSE
THERE'S NO WAY THAT THEY CAN
AFFORD LESTER GOING TO LIVE IN
THEIR PARENTS BASEMENT. THE
REAL PAIN OF THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS OUR
NEIGHBORS WHO ARE LIVING IN
THEIR CAR OR A VAN AND GETTING
UP TO WORK EVERY DAY AND TAKE
THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL AND GOING
TO SLEEP IN A CAR OR IN A
HOMELESS SHELTER WORKOUTS
SURFING. THE REAL PAIN OF
FAMILIES WHO ARE FORCED TO
LEAVE THEIR COMMUNITY OR LEAVE
THE STATE ENTIRELY BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT ENVISION A FUTURE FOR
THEMSELVES IN TERMS OF HAVING
HOUSING. WHEN IT COMES TO
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA WE CAN NO
LONGER AFFORD ARE BROKEN STATUS
QUO. IT WILL TAKE MANY
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO SOLVE
THIS TERRIBLE CRISIS WE'VE HAD
IN SOME AMAZING WORK IN THIS
BODY OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
AND I APPLAUD THAT. BUT OUR
WORK IS NOT DONE. SENATE BILL
FIFTY ADDRESSES ONE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL MATHEMATICAL
LIMITATIONS ON OUR ABILITY AS A
STATE TO HAVE ENOUGH HOUSING
FOR EVERYONE WHO NEEDS A-
RESTRICTIVE. EXCLUSIONARY
ZONING THAT PREVENTS THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. HENCE THE DESTRUCTIVE
CONSTRUCTION OF APARTMENT
BUILDINGS IN THE LARGE MAJORITY
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ZONING IS SORT OF BORING BUT
IT'S FOUNDATIONAL IT IS A MATH
EQUATION IT SETS A BASELINE
ABOUT HOW MUCH HOUSING IS LEGAL
TO BUILD. YOU CAN HAVE THE MOST
STREAMLINED PROCESS IN THE
WORLD YOU CAN HAVE ENORMOUS
FIVE OF FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT IF THE ZONING SAYS
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO BUILD
SOMETHING. THAT THE END OF THE
PROCESS. RESTRICTIVE ZONING
PUTS A HARD CAP FULL STOP WHEN
OUR ABILITY TO BUILD ENOUGH
HOUSING TO GET OUT OF THIS
CRISIS. RESTRICTIVE ZONING ALSO
LEADS TO SPRAWL. BROUGHT
BECAUSE IF YOU CAN'T BUILD
WHERE THE JOBS IN THE TRANSIT
ARE YOU JUST GOING TO BUILD
FURTHER AND FURTHER OUT. IT
DESTROYS FARM LANDS AND OPEN
SPACE. IT CLOGS ARE FREEWAYS TO
THE POINT WHERE THEY BECOME
INCAPACITATED. IT PUSHES OUR%
NEIGHBORS INTO MULTI HOUR
COMMUTES WHERE PEOPLE ARE
SPENDING THREE OR FOUR OR MORE
HOURS A DAY. ON THE ROAD IT
INCREASES CARBON EMISSIONS AND
MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE. FOR US TO
BE OUR CAR OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
WE'RE CURRENTLYFALLING BEHIND
ON OUR CLIMATE GOALS IN
CALIFORNIA. PRECISELY BECAUSE
WE ARE PUSHING PEOPLE INTO THE
SUPER COMMUTES BECAUSE WE DON'T
BUILD ENOUGH HOUSING WHERE THE
JOBS ARE. RESTRICTED TWENTY
INCH IS THAT HOW. IS
PERPETUALLY EXPENSIVE AND OUT
OF REACH FOR MOST CALIFORNIANS.
SB FIFTY WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
CLOSE ITS MASS THAT MASSIVE
HOUSING DEFICIT AND DO SO IN A
WAY THAT DOESN'T CREATE SPRAWL
THAT IS SUSTAINABLE. SO HOW DO
WE GET TO THIS POINT WHERE WE
HAVE A MULTI MILLION HOME
DEFICIT AND WE ARE BASICALLY
BOTTOM OF THE BARREL AMONG THE
FIFTY STATES IN OUR HOUSING
SUPPLY. IT DIDN'T JUST HAPPEN
RANDOMLY IT HAPPENED BECAUSE OF
DELIBERATE ANTI HOUSING POLICY
CHOICES THE CALIFORNIA AND OUR
CITIES HAVE MADE OVER THE LAST
FIFTY YEARS WE HAVE
SYSTEMATICALLY DE PRIORITIZE
HOUSING. AND WE HAD A AT IN IN
IN A FACT A POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IS NOT A
PRIORITY TO HAVE ENOUGH HOUSING
FOR EVERYONE WHO NEEDS A- WE'VE
MADE A CHOICE. THAT THE WAY A
NEIGHBORHOOD LOOKS. THAT VIEWS
ARE MORE IMPORTANT TO WHOSE
ACTUALLY ABLE THEN WHO'S
ACTUALLY ABLE TO LIVE IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD. NOW FOR THE FIRST
HUNDRED AND THIRTY YEARS
CALIFORNIA EXISTED WE DIDN'T DO
IT THIS WAY WE LET PEOPLE BUILD
APARTMENT BUILDINGS ALL OVER
THE PLACE AND THAT'S WHY WE
BUILT SO MUCH HOUSING IN THE
FIFTIES AND THE SIXTIES
SEVENTIES FORTIES WHEN WE WERE
GROWING BY LEAPS AND BOUNDS. WE
SAID BUILD SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
BUT ALSO BUILD APARTMENT
BUILDINGS AND SO WE KEPT UP
WITH POPULATION GROWTH WE USED
TO BUILD AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT
MORE HOUSING THAN WE DO TODAY
WHEN WE WERE SMALLER STATE
BECAUSE WE DID IT THE OLD
FASHIONED WAY. WE BILL ENOUGH
HOUSING TO ACCOMMODATE OUR
GROWTH. AND THEN WE STOP DOING
THAT IN THE SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES SAN FRANCISCO DOWN
ZONES. AND ELIMINATED THE
ABILITY TO HAVE APARTMENT
BUILDINGS AND 70% OF THE CITY
LA DID IN THE EIGHTIES. AND 75%
OF THE CITY. AND WE
SYSTEMATICALLY DECIDED WE'RE NO
LONGER GOING TO ALLOW ENOUGH
HOUSING FOR THE PEOPLE THAT DID
IT. OTHER CITIES AND SUBURBS
QUICKLY FOLLOWED SUIT. THIS HAS
HAD PROFOUND CONSEQUENCES FOR
OUR ECONOMY FOR OUR
ENVIRONMENT. FOR PEOPLE'S
QUALITY OF LIFE AND FOR THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR COMMUNITIES IT
HAS PUT A FUNDAMENTAL
IMPEDIMENT. IN CALIFORNIA'S
ABILITY TO BE A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE CAN COME HERE AND MAKE
LIVES FOR THEMSELVES. WHERE
YOUNG PEOPLE CAN BE A PART OF
OUR COMMUNITY AND HAVE HOPE
THAT THEY WILL HAVE A FUTURE.
AND THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO BE
AS A STATE THAT IS CREATIVE AND
DIVERSE AND INNOVATIVE DOT IS A
THREAT BECAUSE WE HAVE DE
PRIORITIZE HOUSIN. SO
SIGNIFICANTLY SB FIFTY ALL IT
DOES IS READ LEGAL OFFICE.
APARTMENT BUILDING SMALL TO MID
SIZE APARTMENT BUILDINGS IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT REALLY
LIES IS ON AND MANY OF THE
PLACES. WHERE THEY WERE LEGAL
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY YEARS
BEFORE WE BEGAN ON. THIS IS
NOTHING NEW WE'RE JUST SAYING
LET'S GO BACK TO THE ERA WHEN
WE ACTUALLY WERE BUILDING A
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE. NOW I WANT
TO BE CLEAR ABOUT SB FIT DOES
WHAT IT DOSN'T DO. THERE'S
BEEN AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
HYPERBOLE ABOUT THIS BILL I
HAVE NO PROBLEM DEFENDING ANY
BILL THAT I'M OFFERING I DO
HAVE A PROBLEM WHEN PEOPLE PUT
OUT INFORMATION THAT
DRAMATICALLY EXAGGERATES OR
SPREADS AND ACCURATE
INFORMATION. THERE ARE MAILERS
GOING INTO ALMOST ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS RIGHT NOW. THAT
CONTAIN BALD FACED LIES ABOUT
THIS BILL. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE KNOW WHAT THE FACTS ARE.
THERE'S BEEN TALK THAT THIS IS
GOING TO LEAD THE HIGH RISES
AND SKYSCRAPERS. IN
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT IS NOT TRUE.
THIS BILL OVERWHELMINGLY
DIFFERS TO LOCAL HIGHER LIMITS
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
GEOGRAPHY COVERED BY THIS BILL
INCLUDING IN LA INCLUDING IN
THE BAY AREA IS SUBJECT TO THE
LOCALLY ADOPTED HI LIMIT SO IF
YOU HAVE A THIRTY FOOT HEIGHT
LIMIT. IN A CITY INSTEAD OF
SAYING OKAY THIRTY FEET BUT
ONLY SINGLE FAMILY NOW IT'S
THIRTY P. BUT YOU CAN PUT A
MULTI UNIT BUILDING THERE. THE
BILL DOESN'T CHANGE THE SIZE OF
BUILDINGS WILL BE CALL SETBACKS
THE BALK THE WITH THE AND THE
LENGTH OF THE BILL. LOCAL RULES
FILLED. IT IS THAT THIS LEADS
US GUYS ARE RISE WHICH WE'VE
HEARD IT'S JUST NOT ACCURATE.
THERE IS ALSO A NARRATIVE THAT
SB FIFTY ENDS LOCAL CONTROL OF
LAND USE THAT IS ALSO
INACCURATE- AS I MENTIONED
LOCAL HEIGHT LIMITS AND BALK
STANDARD FOR BUILDINGS WILL
STILL APPLY LOCAL DESIGN
STANDARDS WILL STILL APPLY.
STILL EVERY ABILITY TO RESTRICT
BAND DEMOLITIONS OF BUILDINGS
LOCAL APPROVAL PROCESS LOCAL
IMPACT FEES AND SO ON AND SO
FORTH CITIES WILL STILL GET TO
SET THOSE CITIES WILL HAVE
ENORMOUS FLEXIBILITY IN TWO
WEEKS AGO OR THREE WEEKS AGO WE
I'D IN ADDITION SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE. THAT GIVE CITIES THE
ABILITY TO CRAFT THEIR OWN
ALTERNATIVE PLAN TO SB FIFTY
THAT TED IS TAILORED TO THE
NEEDS OF THOSE CITIES. WE ARE
CURRENTLY AS WE SPEAK WORKING
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CITIES ARE
NOT PROVISION TO FLUSH IT OUT
EVEN MORE AND MAKE SURE IT IS
IT'S EASY TO USE AS POSSIBLE
FOR THE CITIES I AM COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH OUR CITIES. AND
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CITIES IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE I DON'T FOR
SUPPORTING OR OPPOSING THIS
BILL I WILL WORK WITH YOU WE
ARE WE ARE MY ARM OUT AS I DO
THE LEADERS. WHATEVER OUR
DISAGREEMENTS AS A PARTNER IN
MAKING SURE THAT THE STRONG
LOCAL CONTROL PROVISIONS IN
THIS BILL ARE IS IMPLEMENTABLE
AS POSSIBLE. SO THERE ALSO SOME.
WHICH I SHARE AN A VERY SAN TO.
ABOUT GINGER. AND DISPLACEMENT.
SB FIFTY IS ABOUT ADDING NEW
HOUSING SO THAT MORE PEOPLE CAN
HAVE HOUSING. IT'S AN ADDED A
BILL. IT IS NOT ABOUT REPLACING
EXISTING COMMUNITIES WE'VE DONE
THAT BEFORE. THE STATE IN THE
PAST WITH REDEVELOPMENT WHEN
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES WERE
BULLDOZED IN VICE CITY AND
OTHER CITIES AND THAT IS WRONG.
AND THAT IS WHY WE HAVE PUT THE
STRONGEST TENET AND ANTI
DEMOLITION PROTECTIONS IN THIS
BILL IN EXISTENCE UNDER STATE
LAW. PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
STRONGER THAN THOSE IN THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE CITIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE
WORK THROUGH THOSE WITH
ADVOCATES WHO ADVOCATE FOR LOW
INCOME RENTERS AND I AM PROUD
OF THOSE PROTECTIONS. IF YOU IF
THERE'S BEEN A RENTER LIVING ON
THE PROPERTY AT ANY POINT IN
THE LAST SEVEN YEARS. YOU
CANNOT GET A DEMOLITION PERMIT
FOR AN SB FIFTY PROJECT EVEN IF
THE WHOLE CITY WOULD OTHERWISE
GRANTED TO YOU. IF THERE'S BEEN
AN ALLIS ACTED ACTION ANY POINT
IN THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS. YOU
CAN'T GET A DEMOLITION PERMIT
FOR THE BUILDING EVEN IF THE
CITY WOULD GIVE IT TO YOU. WE
HAVE AN AFFORDABILITY PROVISION
IN THIS BILL RANGING FROM 15%
TO TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. I WANT
TO STRESS WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WORK ON A OF BILLET I SPOKE TO
THE- WE ARE IN. TO GO TENS WITH
BROAD. WIDE HOUSING EQUITY CALL.
AND WILL CAN. TO WORK WITH THEM
AND WE ARE I BELIEVE VERY CLOSE
TO AN AGREEMENT. ON A BILL
PROUD OF THAT WORK.
IMPLEMENTATION THE BILL IS
DELAY. FOR FIVE. AND WHAT WE
CALL SO. TO COMMUNITIES OUT THE-
LOW INCOME. AND AT RISK OF
DISPLACEMENT TO GIVE THOSE
COMMUNITIES MORE TIME- THE
PLAN. WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH GROUPS LIKE ACT LA AND
PUBLIC COUNCIL IN PUBLIC
ADVOCATE. AND POLICY LINK AND
SO FORTH. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS BILL. IS AS EQUITABLE AS
POSSIBLE THAT IS MY GOAL. WE'RE
NOT ALL THE WAY THERE YEAH. ON
THIS BILL BUT WE WILL GET THERE
AND I'M A 100% COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE BROAD ENGAGEMENT. WE
HAVE ALSO TAKEN MANY MANY.
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL. AS
WE'VE GONE TO THIS TO YOUR
PROCESS I HAVE HAD AN OPEN
DOOR. WITH AGAIN CRITICS
SUPPORTERS AND EVERYONE IN
BETWEEN I HAVE TRAVELED TO
VARIOUS PARTS OF THE STATE. TO
MEET WITH AND SPEAK WITH LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS NEIGHBORS AND
TAKE THAT INPUT. AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT. AS THIS
MOVES TO THE ASSEMBLY AND
COLLEAGUES I AM ASKING YOU TO
GIVE ME AND OUR COALITION THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP WORKING ON
THIS BILL AND THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. AND TO MAKE IT AS
GREAT. AS IT CAN BE. YOU KNOW I
RESPECTED THEIR MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY WHO DON'T SUPPORT THIS
BILL. I RESPECT THAT THIS IS A
DEMOCRACY AND WE ALL IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE WE KNOW FROM
THE VOTERS THAT THIS IS THE
NUMBER ONE OR NUMBER TWO ISSUE
ALONG WITH HOMELESS. I VOTERS
ONE UP ACT. THEY WANT US TO
TAKE. BOLD ACTION THEY WANT US
TO STOP THE PAIN. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO DO THAT
THIS ISN'T A SILVER BULLET
THERE ARE MANY OTHER THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO DO. BUT THIS IS
A BIG STEP AND IT WILL SEND A
PROFOUNDLY POWERFUL MESSAGE TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
WE IS THERE ARE ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES GET IT AND THAT
WE INTEND TO TRY TO MOVE THE
DIAL. TO MAKE THE SITUATION
BETTER. SB FFTY IS AN
OVERNIGHT SOLUTION. THIS IS
GOING TO IT'S THICKNESS FIFTY
YEARS TO DIG INTO THIS WHOLE
IT'S GOING TO TAKE THIS TIME TO
DIG OUT. BUT SB FIFTY WILL HELP
PLANT THE SEEDS SO THAT IN THE
FUTURE OUR KIDS AND OUR
GRANDKIDS DON'T HAVE TO HAVE
THE SAME PAIN. THAT PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING TODAY COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
MADAM PRO TEM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I'M ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SB FIFTY.
AND I VOTE TODAY MEANS WE KEEP
DISCUSSIONS GOING ON HOW
CALIFORNIA CAN REACH SB FIFTIES
GOAL OF BUILDING MORE
AFFORDABLE HOMES AFFORDABLE%
HOMES IT WILL ALSO INCREASE
ACCESS TO JOBS REDUCE THE TIME
PEOPLE HAVE TO SPEND IN THEIR
CARS. AND HELP ME CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE CHANGE TARGETS. TO THE
SENATOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
INTRODUCING SB FIFTY AND FOR
YOUR HER BROKE EFFORTS TO GET
THE BILL WHERE IT IS TODAY. AS
YOU KNOW I ASK FOR THE BILL TO
COME TO THE FLOOR HOPING THAT
THERE HAD BEEN ENOUGH
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS WILL
ALLOW THE BILL TO MOVE FORWARD.
THE DEBATE WE ARE ABOUT TO HAVE
WILL SHOW WHETHER OR NOT THEY
GOAL HAS BEEN ACHIEVED. I KNOW
THAT MANY SENATORS AND MANY OF
THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
REPRESENT HAVE REAL CONCERNS
ABOUT SB FIFTY. AND LET ME
ASSURE YOU THAT I HEAR YOU AND
I ACKNOWLEDGE THE CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILL A BILL
OF THIS MAGNITUDE. IF THE BILL
IS SUCCESSFUL TODAY THERE MUST
BE GOOD FAITH EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS AND I
THINK THE AUTHOR HAS HEARD THAT.
IS SB FIFTY ARE PERFECT I THINK
AS YOU'VE HEARD I KNOW I KNOW
THAT SEVERAL OF YOU HAVE IDEAS
FOR IMPROVEMENT AND YOU'VE
SHARED THOSE COMMENTS. I KNOW
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS IDEAS. I
URGE AN AYE VOTE TODAY BECAUSE
THAT PROVIDES THE TIME WE NEED
FOR THOSE IDEAS AND POTENTIALLY
OTHERS TO BE INCLUDED IN THE
MIX. SB FIFTY IS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST PROFILE BILLS- PROFILE
BILLS WE HAVE CONSIDERED IN THE
SENATE. IT IS ALSO ONE WHERE
THERE'S BEEN TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION BETWEEN
THE MEMBERS OF OUR RESPECTIVE
CAUCUSES AT WE KNOW THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. BUT WEIGHING
ALL THATCAREFULLY I WOULD ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE FOR SB FIFTY
TODAY AND FOR EVEN MORE WORK ON
THE BILL TO START IMMEDIATELY
THANK YOU. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM
PRESIDENT SIR AS OTHERS HAVE
SAID THE AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE
THE SENATOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO
DESERVES A GREAT DEAL OF CREDIT
FROM ALL OF US. ALL OF US. FOR
TAKING ON SUCH A CRITICAL ISSUE.
FOR TAKING ON THE BIG STUFF AND
FORCING US TO ASK THE BIG
QUESTIONS. AND I ALSO THANK THE
PRO TEM. OR THE MANNER IN WHICH
SHE HAS COMPORTED THIS OPEN AND
INCLUSIVE DISCUSSION. FOR ALL
OF US. AS SET FORTH. IN THE
LÏNG FLEA FINDINGS IN THIS
BILL. AND IT'S ALL OF US KNOW
HEREON THE FLOOR TODAY FROM
OUR OWN COMMUNITIES. THERE ARE
COMPELLING REASONS WHY WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THIS DEEP AND URGENT
CRISIS. A CRISIS FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS FOR
FAMILIES STRUGGLING TO KEEP A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS. AND FOR
NEIGHBORHOODS UNRAVELED IN THE
FACE OF DESPERATION REAL PEOPLE
REAL IMPACTS ON THEIR LIVES AND
THEIR HOPES AND THEIR DREAMS
AND THEIR OPPORTUNITIES. BUT
THE THESIS OF MY COMMENTS TODAY
ON THIS FLOOR. COMES DOWN TO
THIS GETTING IT RIGHT IS JUST
AS URGENT GETTING IT RIGHT IS
JUST AS URGENT TOO OFTEN. ALL
OF US BID ARE CONSUMED BY THE
IMMEDIATE ISSUE AT HAND AND WE
BIND OURSELVES TO THE
UNFORGIVING LAW OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. WELL I HAVE BEEN
DOING A GREAT DEAL OF THINKING
ON THIS ISSUE TYPICALLY
RELATING TO AFFORDABILITY I
WILL LIMIT MY COMMENTS TODAY
THE THREE IMPORTANT POINTS.
FIRST THE PREMISE OF THIS BILL
IS THAT MAYORS AND CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS OF SOME OF OUR FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO CITIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
STANDING IN THE WAY OF
HOMEBUILDING AT THE BEHEST OF
SINGLE FAMILY. HOMEOWNERS WELL
THERE MAY BE SOME MERIT TO THIS
NOTION IN LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES. THIS SWEEPING
GENERALIZATION BOTH IT OVER
SIMPLIFIES THE PROBLEM. AN
UNNECESSARILY DEMEANS PEOPLE
WHO WITH NOTHING DONE NOTHING
MORE THAN MAKE HOMES FOR
THEMSELVES RAISE A FAMILY AND
PLAY BY THE RULES. AND NOW THIS
MEASURE AND I JUST TALKED TO
THE CITY TO CONFIRM THIS SEEKS
TO IMPOSE NEW RULES FOR
NEIGHBORHOODS IN NEARLY 80% OF
LOS ANGELES. WE HAVE GIVEN
THERE'S A CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
A FALSE CHOICE ON THE ONE HAND
WE SAID HOUSING ELEMENTS SET
HOUSING GOALS AND YET ON THE
OTHER HANDAS THEY WORK TO
PROVIDE POLICE FIRE AND OTHER
IT'S ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO
RESIDENTS. THEY HAVE BEEN CASH
STARVED THE ONLY AVENUE
AVAILABLE IN PRINCIPLE IS THE
BRADLEY BURNS UNIFORM SALES TAX
WHICH ALLOCATES ONE CENT FOR
EACH DOLLAR OF SALES TO CITIES.
THE REAL BUT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WHICH TO GIVE A
CITIES A REASON TO SAY YES TO
AUTO MALLS YES THE BIG BOX
RETAIL STORES WHICH WOULD ADD
CITY FUNDING BUT SAY NO TO
HOUSING THE FISCAL IS ATION OF
LAND USE WHICH WOULD INCREASE
COSTS OF PROVIDING SERVICES.
THAT IS THE SIMPLE SPEECH
BIGGEST REASON WE ARE WHERE WE
ARE. SECOND THE GOVERNOR IN ALL
OF US IN THIS CHAMBER. WANT TO
BUILD HOUSING URGENCY URGENTLY
THAT IS CLEAR. WE NEED TO START
BUILDING THIS AFTERNOON IF YOU
ASK FOLKS THAT WE REPRESENT.
BUT THIS BILL WILL NOT TAKE
EFFECT UNTIL JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ABOUT A YEAR FROM
NOW. AND THE AMENDMENTS TICKET
JUST THREE WEEKS AGO THE LADY
SP FIFTIES MAJOR PROVISIONS FOR
MORE THAN TWO YEARS TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THE START OF THE
GOVERNOR SECOND TERM. THAT'S
THREE YEARS OF WAITING. NOT
REALLY ADDRESSING THE URGENT
PROBLEMS GETTING HOMES BUILT.
EVEN BEFORE CONSIDERING DELAYS
BASED UPON THE VERY REAL
PROSPECT OF LITIGATION. SO WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE MEANTIME. WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE REAL WORLD. FIVE
A DEVELOPER CONTEMPLATING A
PROJECT THIS BILL REGRETTABLY
AND IRONICALLY HIS ME HUGE
INCENTIVE NOT BUILD NOW BUT
THIS MY HANDS FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS WHY BILL TWO
STORIES WOULD YOU CAN BILL FIVE
STORIES LATER. AND IN LOS
ANGELES YOU COULD NOT PICK A
WORSE TIME TO INADVERTENTLY
POUR SAND IN THE GEARS. WITH
VOTER APPROVAL LOS ANGELES HAS
INCREASED INCENTIVES FOR
BUILDING AFFORDABLE I UNDERLINE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING YOUR TRANSIT.
NEARLY TWENTY THOUSAND UNITS
JUST IN THE LAST TWO YEARS. AND
WATER SINGLE FAMILY HOMEOWNERS
DOING CONTRARY TO THE NOTION
THAT THEY ARE CAUSING THE
PROBLEM MANY ARE AT A RING
ADDING A SESTRI DWELLING UNITS
AN IDEA CARRIED INTO LAW MY
SEAT MATE FROM FREMONT. MY
ABSENCES MADE FROM FREMONT. IN
LOS ANGELES SINCE THE EIGHTY
LAW WAS PASSED WE HAVE HAD ONE
FOURTEEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY APPLICATIONS FILED
JUST TWO YEARS ALMOST TEN
THOUSAND ALREADY PERMITS
ALREADY ISSUED AND MOST OF THEM
ARE IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
WHEN THE COMMUNITY YOU CLAIM.
SOUGHT A TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLAR GRANT AS PART OF A GREEN
TRANSFORMATIVE. COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES UNDER THE
STRATEGICAL COUNSEL YOU DON'T
THEY DID THEIR ENTIRE HOUSING
PLANFOR CLEAN AND GREEN
COMMUNITIES WAS BASED ON EIGHTY
USE NOT BUILDING NEW STUFF BUT
EIGHTY USE BECAUSE IT'S BEEN.
SO WILDLY SUCCESSFUL. THIRD IN
THE PAST I KNOW THE ARGUMENT IS
BEEN MADE HERE ON THE FLOOR BUT
I WANT TO STAND IN THE COUNTRY
POSITION I HAVE STOOD ON THIS
FLOOR. AND HUMBLY ASK MY
COLLEAGUES MANY OF YOU. FOR THE
COURTESY TO MOVE A MEASURE THAT
WAS NOT FULLY DEVELOPED TO THE
OTHER HOUSE AS A WORK IN
PROGRESS. A NUMBER OF US HAVE
DONE SO OURSELVES. BUT I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THIS TIME WE'RE IN
A DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES. AS I
MENTIONED EVEN IN THE BEST
CIRCUMSTANCES ARKHAM STANCES SB
FIFTY DOES NOT BECOME LAW UNTIL
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE
ARE STILL IN THE OPENING DAYS
OF THIS YEAR. THIS BILL MAKES
SWEEPING CHANGES TO HUGE SWATHS
OF THE STATE. THERE IS NO
REASON IN MY JUDGMENT THE POINT.
APPS THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE
IS THE PRO TEM SAID THAT WE
FACE TO THE OTHER HOUSE DENYING
OURSELVES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COLLECTIVELY DO THE WORK AND
EFFECTIVELY AND URGENTLY
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM. LET'S DO
THE HOMEWORK TOGETHER LET'S
BUILD ON THE EXTRAORDINARY
HOMEWORK THAT THE AUTHOR OF
THIS MEASURE HAS DONE IN ALL
CORNERS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE INTER
GENERATIONAL CHALLENGES THAT
INFORMS MUCH OF THE FRAMEWORK
OF MEASURE. LET'S GET IT RIGHT
TOGETHER LET'S CRAFT A SOLUTION
TOGETHER THAT SOLVES
EXTRAORDINARY HOUSING
CHALLENGES WE FACE. I INCLUDE
WHERE I STARTED GETTING IT
RIGHT IS JUST AS URGENT AND FOR
THOSE REASONS I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THIS YOUR TODAY. BUT
I PLEDGE EACH ONE OF YOU THE
PRO TEM THAT I WILL WORK AS
HARD AS I CAN ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TO GET IT RIGHT TO
WORK ON THIS BIG PICTURE
PACKAGE TO FIGURE IT OUT TO PUT
IN THE POSITION. WHERE AS- DOWN
PROBABLY UP BEFORE THE CAN.
WHERE THAT WE'RE NOT JUST GOING
TO CHANGE THEIR OWNING. AND
CHANGE THEIR COMPLIANCE
DETRIMENT ALONG ON THE LINE WAS
THAT HAVE BEEN AND WILL
INCREASE A TRANSIT ORIENTED
PROGRAM THAT WILL FOR CAP. AND
GET DONE. VERY MUCH IMPRESSED.
SENATE HUESO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND OF PRESS THEN AND
SENATOR. UP YOU KNOW I I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN CREATING HOW
MY DE FOR MANY YEARS AND I'VE
BEEN- RESPONSIBLE FOR SEVERAL
THOUSAND UNITS IN MY DISTRICT
SOME THAT ARE VERY PROUD OF
THAT HAVE INTRODUCED A VERY
HIGH QUALITY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN MY DISTRICT. AND THAT TOOK
SOME WORK IN THAT TOOK SOME
EFFORT. AND RIGHT NOW THAT WE
HAVE A HOUSING. BLOOM WHERE WE
HAVE A RENT PRICES HAVE NEVER
BEEN HIGHER. AND WHEN I SEE THE
PEOPLE MY DISTRICT SUFFERING
THROUGH THESE EXORBITANT RENT.
PRICES THAT THAT ARE JUST
UNBELIEVABLE I DON'T KNOW HOW
PEOPLE CAN AFFORD TO LIVE IN
OUR STATE. I CAN'T EXPLAIN WHY
WE DON'T HAVE A GREATER SUPPLY
OF APARTMENTS UNDER
CONSTRUCTION. AND AS I'VE GONE
TO INVESTORS ASKING THEM WHY
ARE YOU BUILDING MORE. I MEAN
WITH RENT PRICES AT THIS RATE.
WHY ARE YOU BUILDING MORE AND
THE PRIMARY RESPONSE FROM THEM
IS WHERE. WHERE CAN WE BUILD
WHERE DOES OWNING ALLOW US TO.
BUILD UNITS THAT WE CAN- TURN A
PROFIT IN EVEN EVEN AT THESE
EXORBITANT RENT RATES AND
THAT'S THAT'S CONCERNING. YOU
KNOW- I'VE BEEN I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN IN IN THIS MAN FOR
MANY YEARS. AND SEEING A BILL
LIKE THIS SINCE YOU KNOW HOW
THIS BILL IS GOING TO AFFECT MY
DISTRICT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THIS IS THIS IS. THIS BILL
FOLLOW SOME VERY BASIC
PRINCIPLES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SMART GROWTH. INTRODUCING
HOUSING WHERE YOU HAVE MASS
TRANSIT THAT MAKES AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF SENSE. I LOOKED AT
THIS BILL IT JUST MAKES A- A
NORMS NONSENSE TO ME AS PEOPLE
SAY IT THIS IS GOOD ELIMINATE
RESIDENTIAL ZONING AND I LOOK
AT THE ZONING. THAT'S CLOSE TO.
TO A MASS TRANSIT WE REALLY
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF SINGLE
FAMILY RESIDENCE CLOSE TREND
I'M HOPING AS FOR AS FAR AS MY
OCCUR COMING. CAN ONE OF THE
REASONS SEVEN MAINLY GOT ME OUT
TO RUN FOR OFFICE. WAS AN
EXPERIENCE THAT I HAD IN MY
COMMUNITY AND MAYBE YOU'VE HAD
THE SAME EXPERIENCE. THE
COMMUNITY THAT I LIVE IN
SOUTHEAST SAN DIEGO HAD A
COMMUNITY PLAN THAT WAS UPDATED
IN NINETEEN. EIGHTY SEVEN. ANY
RESPONSE TO HIGH CRIME RATES-
THE LEADERS OF THE CITY AT THAT
TIME DECIDED TO DOWN ZONE. SO A
LOT OF RESIDENTIAL ZONING THAT
WAS THAT ALLOWED SIX UNITS. WAS
DOWN ZONE TO TWO UNITS NOT TALK
ABOUT MOVIE IN. THE MOVING THE
GOAL POST DURING THE
COMPETITION. HERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS THAT PAID A PREMIUM
FOR. THE RESIDENTIAL LEASE ON
LAND THAT WAS THAT ALLOWED SIX
UNITS. AND IT WAS DOWNS OF THE
TWO UNITS THAT'S LIKE TAKING
MONEY OUT OF PEOPLE'S POCKETS
AND WHAT IT REALLY RESULTED IN
HIS BLOOD OF PEOPLE NOT TEARING
DOWN OF UNITS WHERE THEY HAD
FOUR UNITS ALREADY BECAUSE THEY
COULD ONLY BE REBUILT TWO UNITS
AND IF THEY HAD SIX UNITS SO
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF- UNITS IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. THE AMERICAN
REPLACE I CAN'T REPLACE A DOES
MAKE FINANCIAL SENSE REPLACE
AND SO WE HAVE A LOT OF THE
UPDATED UNITS THAT PEOPLE. WANT
TO REINVENT AND BECAUSE THEY
CAN REBUILD. AND I THINK I THE
REASON I'M I'M- RAISING THIS IS
AN ISSUE BECAUSE YOU PROBABLY
HAD. THAT SAME EXPERIENCE IN
YOUR COMMUNITY BECAUSE WHAT
HAPPENED IN THOSE YEARS IN THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SINCE THEN. THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF DOWN ZONING THAT'S OCCURRED
SINCE THEN. SO IF YOU CONSIDER
THAT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
THE POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA
WAS TWENTY EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE.
AND TODAY WE HAVE FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE IN IN THAT PERIOD WE'VE
SEEN A LOT OF A DOWN ZONING
TAKE PLACE. IF YOU IF YOU KNOW
MATH IT'S A VERY SIMPLE ISSUE
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF SUPPLY AND
DEMAND AND IF WE'VE LOWERED.
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE THAT
SUPPLY WE ONLY HAVE DEMAND
INCREASING. AND NO ABILITY. TO
PROBLEM THIS BILL DOESN'T GET
TO THE PRIMARY ISSUE WHAT IT'S
GOING TO HELP IT'S GOING TO
HELP IS IT GONNA DESTROY
RESIDENTIAL ZONING AS SOME
CLAIM NO IS IT GONNA GO AS FAR
AS SOME PEOPLE FEAR IT MIGHT
ABSOLUTELY NOT BUT WILL IT MAKE
A DIFFERENCE ABSOLUTELY YES. IT
WILL. AND I THINK TALK IS CHEAP
AS LONG AS I'VE BEEN HERE WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE
WE'VE MADE SOME GAINS. WE'VE
MADE SOME GAINS WE HAVE FUNDED
OF SOME FOR HOUSING BUT AS FAR
IS REALLY ADDRESSING THE SUPPLY
ISSUE WE HAVE NOT DONE THAT.
AND AS OUR GOVERNOR COMES IN
MAKING SOME PROMISES TO BUILD
SEVERAL MILLION UNITS. I DON'T
KNOW HOW WE'RE GONNA DO THAT
UNDER THE CURRENT SITUATION IN
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL WILL AT
LEAST PROVIDE SOME ABILITY TO
DELIVER ON THAT PROMISE IT'LL
PROVIDE SOME ABILITY OF THIS
LEGISLATURE. TO PRO PROVIDE
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND WE
CAN CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT
SUPPLEMENT TEAM THAT WITH WITH
MORE FUNDING. AND SUPPORT FOR
THE LOCAL CITIES TO DO THAT BUT
THE POLITICAL WILL- THAT'S NOT
EXIST AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IS NOT
ENOUGH TO CHANGE WHAT THE
NUMBERS ON THE SUPPLIES SO. I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
MEASURE. AND TO KEEP THE
CONVERSATION GOING. THERE'S NO
REASON WHY WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT THIS IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND LET'S KEEP THIS
BILL ALIVE SO WE CAN DO THAT
THANK YOU MEMBERS. SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. REGULAR HERE
THROUGHOUT THIS DEBATE. A FAIR
AMOUNT OF UNITY ON ON ONE FACT
THAT WE ARE IN A CRISIS ONE OF
HOMELESSNESS ONE A HOUSING IN
THE STATE. AND I WOULD ADD A
THIRD WHICH IS THE CLIMATE
EMERGENCY. NOW SOME OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY. HAVE
SPOKEN UP IN FAVOR THIS MEASURE
AS I HAVE THROUGHOUT MY CAREER
IN FACT THAT WE NEED MORE
HOUSING NEAR TRANSIT TO REDUCE
THE AMOUNT PEOPLE DRIVE SO WE
CAN REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF PATROL
AND WE USE THAT WE CAN REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF POLLUTION IN THE
STATE. AND I AGREE WITH THAT
PREMISE I ALSO AGREE THAT WE DO
NEED TO BUILD MORE. BUT I DO
NOT BELIEVE. THAT IN ORDER TO
MEET THE CHALLENGES OF THOSE
CRISES. THAT WE HAVE TO CREATE
NEW ONES. AND. YOU CAN ONLY
LOOK BACK TO LAST FALL. AND
THROUGHOUT THESE LAST YEAR'S.
WHERE WILDFIRES HAVE TORN
THROUGH. NOT THE HINTERLANDS.
BUT A NEW CLASS OF NEIGHBORHOOD.
EXTENDING DEEPER INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND EVER BEFORE.
THEY CALL THIS THE WE- THE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE AND
THOSE OF YOU WHO HAD PEOPLE
LOSE HOMES OR LOSE THEIR LIVES
NO THESE AREAS NOW ALL TOO WELL.
THEY LOOK BEAUTIFUL. AND
THEY'RE ALSO DEADLY. AND IT'S
TIME WE STOP DEVELOPING AS A
STATE INTO THE WILD IN URBAN
INTERFACE PERIOD. THERE IS NO
LAW ON THE BOOKS RIGHT NOW IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT
LIMITS THAT HUNGER FOR GROWTH
INTO THOSE REGIONS. AND WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING IS
BURNING MORE AND MORE
CALIFORNIANS HOMES DOWN THE
MORE WE BUILT IN THERE. IN TURN
RED TAX OUR INSURANCE SYSTEM.
WHERE TO PUT A DRAIN ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND ULTIMATELY AS
THE RECEIVERS UP HERE WE'RE
GONNA END UP FOOTING THE BILL
FOR TAXPAYERS IN CALIFORNIA. SO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A DEBATE ABOUT
HOUSING TODAY. SO I WANT TO
TELL YOU ABOUT ONE EXAMPLE.
WHEN THE WALLS THE FIRE TORE
THROUGH THE DISTRICT I
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE I WORK FOR.
BURNED A LOT OF PEOPLE I KNOWS
HOMES DOWN BURN MY PLACE DOWN.
BURN A LOT OF MY FRIENDS DOWN.
I CAN GET BACK ON MY FEET
THOUGH. I GOT A FAMILY THAT. I
CAN GO CRASH ON THEIR COUCH IN.
GOT EDUCATION AND A GOOD JOB
HERE. AND CAN COULD PULL MYSELF
BACK UP A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO. WHAT'S HAPPENING
NOW IN CITIES ALL THROUGHOUT
THAT REGION HIT BY THAT FIRE
AND SO MANY OTHER FIRES. IS
UNDER EVEN CURRENT LAW THEY'RE
BEING FORCED TO PLAN NEW
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS MULTI
FAMILY PROJECTS IN THAT SAME
REA THE JUST BURNED DOWN
LITERALLY IN THE ASHES OF THE
WALLS THE FIRE I HAVE CITIES
THAT ARE TRYING TO NOW TO MEET
STATE LAW BUILD FURTHER IN THAT
AREA. THAT SEEMS INCREDIBLY
BACKWARDS TO ME. AND I WOULD
NOTE THAT THE AUTHOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
ENDS. I BELIEVE THE SENSITIVE
TO IT. I DON'T IMPUGN ANY
INTENT HERE. BUT THOSE OF YOU
TO TELL YOU THAT THE BILL EXAMS
HI FIRE SEVERITY ZONES FOR MANY
THIS UP ZONING WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE TODAY. IS MISREADING
THE TEXT. AND I'LL QUOTE HERE
FOR A MOMENT. FROM THE BILL SO
IN SIX IN SECTION SIX FIVE NINE
ONE EIGHT DOT TWO TWO THOSE ARE
YOU READING ALONG. THE TOP OF
PAGE FORTY SIX. WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY SAYS THAT IF YOU'RE
IN A VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY
ZONE. YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
IMPACTED BY THE OF ZONING
REQUIRED. UNLESS YOU ADOPTED A
MITIGATION MEASURE QUOTE
UNQUOTE A MITIGATION MEASURE.
EVERY SINGLE CITY I WORK FOR
HAS ADOPTED SOME KIND OF
MITIGATION MEASURE. THERE FOR
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
CITIES IS STILL IN. AND THEY'RE
STILL SUBJECT TO THE OF ZONING
IN THIS BILL. YOU CALL AN
EXEMPTION WELL THE EXEMPTION OF
THE EXEMPTION HAS HOLES YOU
COULD DRIVE A TRUCK THROUGH.
NOW I KNOW THE AUTHORS
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN TRYING TO
CLOSE SOME OF THOSE LOOPHOLES.
AND THAT'S PART OF THIS SORT OF
WORK IN PROGRESS VERSUS TRY TO
GET IT RIGHT THE FIRST TIME
CONVERSATION WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TODAY. BUT THIS VOTE IS TO
SERIOUS. TO JUST TRUST IN THE
PROCESS AND LET IT GO. YOU KNOW
WE ALL HAVE TO GO HOME AND BE
TRUE TO OUR OUR FOLKS. BUT I
CAN'T IN GOOD CONSCIENCE
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
KNOWING THAT. I'M MAKING THE
PROBLEM WORSE. NOW THERE HAVE
BEEN EXEMPTIONS GRANTED IN THIS
LEGISLATION TO BE CLEAR. THOSE
COMMUNITIES MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
EXEMPTED BUT CERTAINLY
COMMUNITIES LIVING IN COUNTIES
UNDER SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND HAVE.
NOW TO THOSE COUNTIES THE
STILLER SUBJECT TO SUM UP
ZONING RESTRICT SOME UP ZONING
REQUIREMENTS NEAR- KEY TRANSIT
HUBS. SO THERE WILL STILL BE
SOME MODEST UP ZONING IN THOSE
SMALLER COUNTIES IF THEY'VE GOT
A TRAIN LINE GOING THROUGH. BUT
I DON'T CARE THE MALIBU IS OUT
OF THIS BILL. I GREW UP THERE I
LOVE THAT COMMUNITY BUT-
THEY'RE NOT THE FOLKS THAT. I'M
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY IN AND
FRANKLY IF MALIBU AND MARINE
ARE OUT. OR SAN LUIS OBISPO IS
OUT BUT SAN JOAQUIN IS IN AYE
AYE I DON'T GET THE WHY THERE.
THE SANTA BARBARA IS OUT BUT
VENTURA COUNTY IS IN I DON'T
GET THE WHY. THOMAS FIRE TORE
THROUGH THAT AREA. DOESN'T
MATTER THEY DOING NORTH SIDE OF-THE COUNTY THEIR OWN ALWAYS.
TORE THROUGH THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS JUST THE SAME WHY
DIFFERENT TREATMENT. SO I
STRUGGLE WITH THAT. THE
DISPARATE TREATMENT WHEN IT
COMES TO. THESE EXEMPTIONS WE
BUILT INTO THIS LEGISLATION AND
PART OF ME ONCE THEY WILL GET
MY EXEMPTION I WANT TO GET
THOSE OTHER CITIES OUT I WANT
TO CUT THAT DEAL HELP ME GET
AGORA HILLS OUT HELP ME GET
WESLAKE OUT IN CALABASAS IN LET
ME CUT THAT DEAL SAVE THE FOLKS
BACK HOME FROM THIS FEAR OF
MORE FIRE. AND THEN ALL OF DONE
MY JOB. BUT I CAN'T IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE MAKE THIS A BILL
ABOUT. DEALS AND EXEMPTIONS I
TRULY BELIEVE IN THE PURPOSE OF
THE AUTHORS PUTTING FORTH HERE
THAT WE ACTUALLY DO NEED. A
HOUSING SOLUTION IN THE STATE.
THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT ALL
THESE RISKS BUT- DOESN'T MAKE
THE PROBLEM WORSE. I APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE.
AND I RECOGNIZE THAT THE BILL
MAKES IT OUT OF THIS HOUSE
TODAY YES IT COULD CHANGE. BUT
WE DO NOT HAVE TO EXACERBATE
THE CLIMATE CRISIS WHILE WE TRY
TO SOLVE IT. THAT IS A FALSE
CHOICE. I BELIEVE WE CAN GET
THIS RIGHT. THE PUSH FOR
GENEROSITY. NOT TO EMPOWER NAME
BE ISM. BUT TO SAY YES IN THE
RIGHT BACKYARDS THE LAND HAS TO
DICTATE THE USE. AND WHEN THE
LAND IS TOO DANGEROUS WE HAVE
GOT TO SAY NO. AND WHEN THE
COMMUNITY IS RIGHT WE DO HAVE
TO SAY YES SO I AM. READY TO
SAY YES BUT- WE'VE BEEN THROUGH
TOO MUCH TRAUMA. TO FORCE THIS
ON THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN TORN
DOWN. AT ALL THE COSTS THAT
COME WITH IT HUMAN FISCAL AN
OTHERWISE. SO I REGRETFULLY
RISE IN OPPOSITION IS MEASURE
AND- SHE ATE ALL THE HARD WORK
DONE SO FAR. CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS HOW TO RETURN TO SOME
OF THE COMMENTS OF MY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO. I'M A
NOT A HUGE FAN OF SUPPLY SIDE
ECONOMICS IDEA ACTUALLY LIKE TO
REGULATE MARKETS ESPECIALLY TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS RENTERS
PEOPLE YOU NAME IT BUT SUPPLY
SIDE ECONOMICS ISRAEL AND AS
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
POINTED OUT WE HAVE A SHORTAGE.
WE HAVE A SERIOUS HOUSING
SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT
HOUSING SHORTAGE WHILE ALONE IS
NOT THE SOLE CAUSE OF OUR VERY
HIGH COST OF HOUSING IT IS. I
WOULD ONE WANT TO BE REALLY
CAREFUL I DON'T WANT TO
DIMINISH IT IT IS THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE- NOW. IT
GETS A SIMPLIFIED IN DIFFERENT
AREAS ANY GETS AMPLIFIED IN OUR
HIGH JOB GROWTH AREAS. AND
THOSE SAME HIGH JOB GROWTH
AREAS THAT HAVE NOT BUILT TO
HOUSING ARE THOSE AREAS WERE
NOT ONLY IS THE HOUSING MOST
EXPENSIVE BUT WHERE WE ARE
SEEING THE MOST GENTRIFICATION.
AND DISPLACEMENT. AND WHILE
SUPPLY ALONE WILL NOT STOP THAT
IT IS ESSENTIAL TO STOP IT IT
MUST BE THE SUPPLY MUST BE
ADDED TO STOP IT. NOW LET'S
LOOK AT SOME REAL FAX THE ONLY
PLACES IN THE U. S. WITH HIGH
JOB GROWTH THAT HAVE ALSO SEEN
HOUSING COSTS GO DOWN BOTH RENT
AND HOMEOWNERSHIP ARE THOSE
AREAS WHERE THE HOUSING SUPPLY
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY. BUT
WE'RE NOT THAT PLACE WE ARE NOT
THAT PLACE WE HAVE NOT
INCREASED OUR HOUSING SUPPLY
DRAMATICALLY AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
POINTED OUT IF ANYTHING I DON'T
MEAN ANYTHING WAS JUST HE SAID
IT IT'S REAL. EVERYWHERE ACROSS
OUR STATE. WE DOWN ZONED AND
THAT'S SPEND FOR FORTY YEARS WE
DOWN SOON. ENACT DOWN ZONING
RESULTED IN EXCLUSIVE
NEIGHBORHOODS IT RESULTED IN
THE SITUATION WHERE. THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH THE BEST
SCHOOLS THE BEST PARKS THE BEST
AMENITIES. FEWER AND FEWER
PEOPLE CAN LIVE NOW THERE'S
LOTS OF OTHER REASONS THAT
EXCLUSION HAPPENED LET'S NOT
FOOL OURSELVES MUCH OF THAT
DOWN ZONING STARTED AFTER THE
FAIR HOUSING ACT. WENT INTO
PLACE. AND SO YOU KNOW MUCH OF
OUR ZONING LAWS WERE OUT RATE
IN EXPLICITLY RACIST NOW. EVEN
WITH THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE CONFRONTED THAT WE HAVE
CHANGE SOME POLICIES BUT WE
HAVE NOT CHANGED OUR CITY
POLICIES. CAN'T WE ARE NOT ONLY
THE SHORTAGE THE HOUSING
SHORTAGE WE STILL HAVE THE
EXTREME EXCLUSIVITY. WE HAVE
NOT DONE ENOUGH YET BUT WE HAVE
DONE A LOT AS A LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO LAW
MANY PROTECTIONS FOR.
ESPECIALLY OUR TENANTS LAST
YEAR'S BILL THAT PUT IN THE
HOUSING THE RENTAL CAP LAST
YEAR'S BILL THAT. HAD JUST
BECAUSE EVICTION PROTECTIONS
ACROSS THE STATE ARE THE
INCREASE WE FUNDED FOR LEGAL
SERVICES SO THOSE PEOPLE THAT
WERE FACED WITH. I'M
JUSTIFICATIONS OR UNFAIR OR
WRONG RENT INCREASES ROY RAINY
CREASES THAT DIDN'T COMPLY WITH
THE LAW WOULD HAVE SOME ABILITY
TO GET SOME LEGAL ASSISTANCE
WE'VE ALSO DONE A LITTLE MORE
PROTECTIONS AROUND PEOPLE FOR
WHO MAY FACE FORECLOSURE. OR
WHO MAY BE FACING ON FAIR
LENDING PRACTICES NOT ENOUGH
NOT ENOUGH WE'VE GOT TO DO MORE
THERE BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO DO
MORE FOR SUPPLY. AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES NOW BY THE
VIRTUE OF NOT HAVING ADEQUATE
SUPPLY NOT ONLY HAVE WE SEEN
THIS COSTS GOING UP BUT WE'VE
SEEN THAT PEOPLE ARE DRIVEN
OUT. TO FURTHER AND FURTHER
AWAY FROM THE JOB AREAS AND
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED IN THIS
STATE REACHED AN ALL TIME HIGH
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THERE'S
ONLY GROWING WE DON'T HVE THE
NUMBERS YET FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
BUT THE TREND IS OCT. KNOW WHAT
IS AB ME. WE ALREADY HAVE THE
DIRTIEST AIR IN THE COUNTRY.
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
INCREASING THIRTIES ARE AIR
FURTHER IT JUST EXACERBATES ARE
HEALTH PROBLEMS AND OF COURSE
THE CLIMATE CRISIS. NOW EIGHTY
USED ARE VERY IMPORTANT AND I
SUPPORTED EVERY EIGHTY YOU A
LOT AND EVEN CARRIED THE ONE
THAT THEN GOT PASSED LAST YEAR
UNDERTAKINGS NAME THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY MY BILL. BUT EIGHTY
USE AS IMPORTANT AS THEY ARE
FOR THE SUPPLY AND I'M NEVER
GONNA SPEAK AGAINST THEM THEY
ARE CREATING HOUSING FOR OUR
FAMILIES BY AND LARGE THE UNITS
ARE TOO SMALL WE NEED FAMILY
HOUSING ALSO. SO WE NEED MORE
THAN JUST EIGHTY USE EIGHTY
YEARS ARE NOT GOING TO DO IT
WHAT SB FIFTY DOES IS IT
INCREASES THE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITY IN HIGH JOB GROWTH
AREAS AND TRANSIT RICH AREAS.
AREAS THAT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED FROM NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT HAVE GREAT PARKS GREAT
SCHOOLS AND GREAT AMENITIES.
YEAH AND IT REQUIRES MORE
BUILDING OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAN ANY OF OUR CURRENT LAWS DO
SO YES THERE'S LEGITIMATE
CONCERN THAT PERHAPS THE UNITS
THAT ARE UNDER SB FIFTY THE
BUILDINGS THAT ARE TEN UNITS OR
LESS. DON'T HAVE QUITE THE
LEVEL OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE ONES
ABOVE TEN UNITS HAVE. THAT CAN
BE ADDED BUT IT DOES FOR IT
FREE AND ANY BUILDING OF ELEVEN
UNITS AND HIGHER IT REQUIRES
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAN
ANY OTHER LAW WE HAVE. IT ALSO.
IF I CAN ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE HIGH FIRES AREAS YOU
KNOW EVERY LOUIS IS NOT
EXCLUDED IN THE BILL BUT WHAT
MY COLLEAGUE WHO IS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE HOUSING IN THE HIGH
FIRE AREAS HAS FAILED TO
MENTION IS THAT IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE AN INCREASE IN DENSITY
AND HIGH FIRES AREAS BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS EACH LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FLEXIBILITY AS TO WHERE IF THEY
CHOOSE NOT TO PUT THE INCREASE
DENSITY. IN WHERE THE BILL IS
DESIGNED THEY CAN ADJUST THAT
IT GIVES FLEXIBILITY TO THE TO
THE NEW BILL THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE BILL BEFORE YOU AND YOU CAN
READ IT GIVE FLEXIBILITY TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NOW WHAT I'D
FURTHER SAY IS THAT I WOULD
SUPPORT A BILL. AND I HOPE THAT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THAT WAS YOU
FIRE AREA WOULD PUT INTO PLACE
A BILL THAT WOULD PUT A
MORATORIUM. ON THE BUILDING IN
THE MOST SEVERE HIGH RISK FIRE
AREAS BUT I WOULD STILL NEED TO
YOU. THAT YOU WILL FIND THE
VERY SAME OPPOSITION THE ENTIRE
LEAGUE OF CITIES WOULD OPPOSE
SUCH A BILL. AND EVERY ALMOST
EVERY ENTITY THAT NOW POSES
FIFTY WOULD OPPOSE SUCH A BILL.
SO I THINK IT'S UNFAIR TO
CONFLATE THIS BILL WITH
INCREASING FIRE RISK. BECAUSE
THERE ARE MANY THINGS IN THE
BILL THAT GIVE THE FLEXIBILITY
AND THERE'S ADDITIONALLY THE
POWER OF ALL OF US TO ADDRESS
THE HIGH FIRE AREAS. MAYBE IN
THIS BILL AS IT MOVES ON OR A
SEPARATE BILL BUT YOU WATCH
THAT WILL BE SO CONTROVERSIAL.
SO I DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR TO
CONFLATE THAT. I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH INCREASING SUPPLY.
AND I'M DOING SOME OF THAT
EXCLUSIONARY ZONING THAT HAS
BEEN PUT INTO PLACE OVER THE
LAST FORTY YEARS THAT IS
PREVENTED US FROM GETTING MORE
FOR HOUSING AND MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THOSE AREAS WHERE
EVERYONE MOST WANTS TO LIVE
THOSE AREAS WITH THE HIGH
QUALITY SCHOOLS AND THE HIGH
QUALITY PARKS. AND ALL THE
OTHER AMENITIES AND WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SENATOR BILL. OUR PRESIDENT TO
A MEMBERS. I HAVE A QUALIFIED
YES VOTE ON THIS BILL. AND I'M
VOTING FOR TODAY BECAUSE I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT MOVE
FORWARD. BUT I RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO CHANGE MY VOTE. WHEN
IT COMES BACK TO THE CENTER
FROM THE ASSEMBLY AS WE KNOW
AND I'VE BEEN HERE FOR THIRTEEN
YEARS SOMETIMES BILLS GO TO THE
ASSEMBLY THERE CONTROVERSIAL
THEY COME BACK AND YOU DON'T
EVEN KNOW. WHAT THEY SAY
ANYMORE BECAUSE THEY'RE- OFTEN
CHANGE IN A RADICAL WAY I ALSO
WANT TO HEAR FROM THE GOVERNOR.
GOVERNOR IS GOT A BUDGET HE'S
GONNA BE WORKING ON AND I'M
CURIOUS AS TO. WHAT HIS POLICY
DIRECTIVES ARE ON THAT. NOW SB
FIFTY MAY INCREASE HOUSING
PRODUCTION BUT WILL NOT ADDRESS
ARE HOMELESS CRISIS.
STREAMLINING THE BUILDING
PERMIT PROCESS TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR DEVELOPERS WILL
GENERATE MORE HOUSING UNITS.
BUT THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE
UNITS WILL BE MARKET RATE.
CITIES LIKE MY SAN JOSE AND LOS
ANGELES DESPITE BEST INTENTIONS
ARE STRUGGLING TO KEEP UP WITH
THE EVER GROWING PRODUCTION
NEEDS TO KEEP THE RENT BURDEN
AND A VERY LOW INCOME FAMILIES
OFF OUR STREETS. THE MARKET
RATE HOUSING IS PART OF THE
SOLUTION. BUT WITHOUT
DELIBERATE INVESTMENTS IN
AFFORDABLE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR OUR POOREST THOSE
WITH THE MOST SEVERE NEEDS IT
CONTRIBUTES TO THE RISING COST
OF RANTS AS PROPERTY VALUES
INCREASE ESPECIALLY ALONG
TRANSIT QUARTERS AND THAT'S WHY
THE STATE NEEDS TO INVEST IN
ONGOING FUNDS TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. ESPECIALLY
FOR A POOREST FAMILIES THOSE
MAKING 30% AREA MEDIAN INCOME
OR LOWER. THESE FAMILIES ARE IN
THE HOMELESS PIPELINE NOW
DEVOID OF ANY STATE SUBSIDY
THERE IS NO INCENTIVE TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE PROJECT
SIMPLY WON'T CANCEL OUT AND-
YOU COULD JUST BASICALLY AUS
ANY DEVELOPER. AND THEY'LL SAY
THAT. ALL THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS WE HAVE MADE HISTORICAL
ONE TIME- INVESTMENTS TO
SHELTER THOSE ON OUR CITY
STREETS AND PROVIDED
SIGNIFICANT PLANNING FUNDS TO
GET LOCAL GOVERNMENT INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENTS BUT AS YOU KNOW THE
CRISIS IS SIGNIFICANT. AND
DOORS WHAT CAN BE DONE IN ONE
YEAR OR OR IN ONE BILL. FURTHER
ALL RE RESET REPORTS INDICATE
HOUSING PRODUCTION IS SLOWING
AND WE'RE FALLING EVEN FURTHER
BEHIND. WHAT IS BEEN MISSING
FROM THE SASSER EFFORTS IS THE
ONGOING STATE COMMITMENT TO
QUICKLY BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS TO KEEP UP WITH
DEMAND. OF I'M PUTTING MONEY
WHERE MY MOUTH IS IN THAT
MONDAY WE ANNOUNCED THAT STE
OUR OFFICE BUILDING WHERE MY
OFFICES IN SAN JOSE. WE'RE
PROPOSING THAT THAT BE TORN
DOWN TO BUILD TWELVE HIGH UP TO
TWELVE HUNDRED UNITS OF FACULTY
AND STUDENT HOUSING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR OUR
STUDENTS IT SOUNDS A STATE AND
OUR FAQ OUR LOW INCOME FACULTY
AND STAFF AT THE UNIVERSITY.
THERE ARE TWO POINT TWO MILLION
EXTREME LOW INCOME AND VERY LOW
INCOME RENTER HOUSEHOLDS
COMPETING FORCE ONLY SIX
HUNDRED FIX SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE RENTAL RENTAL HOMES
AND THIS LEAVES ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION OF CALIFORNIA'S LOW
INCOME FAMILIES. WITHOUT ACCESS
TO HOUSING. AT A HIGH RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. ANDWE NEED A
PACKAGE OF LEGISLATION THAT
ADDRESSES BOTH THE SHORT. AND
LONG TERM GOALS. WE DID THIS
TWO YEARS AGO IT WORK WE GOT A
LOT OF GOOD LEGISLATION PASSED
WE CAN DO IT AGAIN. AND WE NEED
TO BE SMARTER MORE STRATEGIC
ABOUT OUR INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
HOUSING POLICIES THE CITY STATE
PARTNERSHIP FOR PRODUCTION.
MUST BE PART OF THE SOLUTION
NOW IT PASSED SB FIFTY CREATES
A PERMANENT PROGRAM. THAT WILL
HELP DEVELOPERS BUILD THE
MARKET RATE HOUSING AND SOME
AFFORDABLE UNITS YEAH- THE
JANUARY BUDGET WE JUST SEEN
CONTINUES TO MAKE TEMPORARY NON
COMMITTAL INVESTMENTS CREATING
UP. OUR NEW PROGRAMS FUNDED
WITH ONE ONE THEY CREATE NEW
PROGRAMS. ANNOUNCING THESE
PROGRAMS BUT THE ONLY FUNDING
FOR ONE YEAR. AT THAT IS
ILLOGICAL AND WE NEED TO MAKES
SURE OUR POOREST FAMILIES
AREN'T PUSHED OUT OF THE
NEIGHBORHOODS THEY GREW UP IN
THE ONLY WAY TO ENSURE THIS TO
CREATE THE ON GOING STATE
FUNDING SOURCE TO SPUR
PRODUCTONS OF THE AFFORDABLE
UNITS SO I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR
THIS BILL TODAY WITH THE CABBIE
OUT. THAT WE DON'T LEAVE BEHIND.
THE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WITHOUT A HOME
AND THOSE THAT ARE ONLY A FEW
STEPS AWAY. FROM THAT HAPPENED
TO THEM. ARJUNA VOTE LET'S KEEP
WORKING TOGETHER. WE GOT A LONG
ROAD AHEAD OF US THIS YEAR
THANK YOU. SENATOR MONNING.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- I WANT TO THANK. ALL
THE COLLEAGUES IN THE AUTHOR
FOR THE- CIVIL AND RESPECTFUL
CONVERSATION HERE THE
UNDERPINNING IS A HOUSING
CRISIS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT HOUSING
CRISIS IS LINKED TO THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. IN MY DISTRICT I'VE
HEARD IN LARGELY IN THE LAST
FORTY EIGHT HOURS FROM CITIES
FROM ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS FROM
TENANTS RIGHTS GROUPS. AND
THEIR SPLIT AND THEY'RE DIVIDED
AS THEIR PERSPECTIVES VERY AND
DIFFER ON HOW THEY THINK. SB
FIFTY MAY IMPACT THEM THEY'RE
COMMUNITY THEIR ORGANIZATIONAL
INTEREST. A COUPLE OF FACTS
THAT ARE IRREFUTABLE IN MY
DISTRICT. IS THAT WE HAVE JOBS.
WHERE WORK FORCE CANNOT AFFORD
TO LIVE. AND SO EVERY DAY IN MY
DISTRICT WE SEE A MIGRATION OF
VEHICLES MOVING FROM EAST TO
WEST. AND THEN WE SEE THAT IN
THE AFTERNOON GOING THE REVERSE
DIRECTION SOME PEOPLE COMMUTING
FOR AN HOUR SOME FOR TWO HOURS
SOME FOR THREE HOURS. AND THE
REASON THEY'RE SPENDING THAT
MUCH TIME IN THEIR CARS IS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
HOUSING IT'S CLOSE TO WHERE
THEY WORK. THOSE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. ARE THE LARGEST
CONTRIBUTOR. TO DIRTY AIR INTO
THE CLIMATE CRISIS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SB FIFTY OFFERS A
PATH FOR US TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING CRISIS I UNDERSTAND
IT'S LINKAGE TO THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. IN THE VOTE TODAY
FRIENDS. A VOTE TO MOVE THE
BILL FORWARD TO FURTHER
COMMITTEE HEARINGS IN THE
ASSEMBLY FURTHER AMENDMENTS AND
IF SUCCESSFUL IN THE ASSEMBLY
IT COMES BACK TO US. SO ARE
VOTE TODAY IS NOT A VOTE ON A
FINAL BILL THAT IS GOING TO
BIND OUR COMMUNITIES IT'S GOING
TO BIND OUR CONSTITUENTS. OUR
YES VOTE TODAY IS A VOTE SAYING
YES THE HOUSING CRISIS IS REAL
YES THE CLIMATE CRISIS IS REAL
AND WE'RE COMMITTING AS A BODY
TO USE THIS VEHICLE AS ONE OF
MANY. TO MOVE THIS CONVERSATION
FORWARD THE BENEFIT OF THIS
BILL ALREADY. IS THE DISENGAGED
OUR COMMUNITIES IT'S ENGAGED
INTEREST GROUPS IT'S ENGAGE NON
PROFITS AND BUILDERS AND TRADES.
IN HAVING PERHAPS THE MOST
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THE CITIES ARE
REPRESENT WHEN I MEET WITH THEM
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IS
HOUSING. AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS. SO FRIENDS. I
DON'T AGREE WITH THOSE WHO SAY
WE SHOULDN'T SUPPORT A BILL
THAT IS NOT PERFECT OR RIGHT OR
THAT WE'VE IRONED OUT ALL THE
CONCERNS WHEN IT'S A BILL IN
PROGRESS GOING THROUGH OUR
PROCESS I ALSO RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO CAST A NO VOTE IF IT
COMES BACK IN HASN'T ADDRESS
SOME OF THE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED. WHEN IT
COMES BACK I STAND CORRECTED.
BUT FRIENDS LET'S NOT CUT THIS
CONVERSATION SHORT. LET'S NOT
OBLIGATION AND RESPONSIBILITY
TO MOVE THIS CONVERSATION
FORWARD TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE CONCERTS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED AND UNDERSTAND
AND I RESPECT THE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE IN IMPACT IN
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES BUT
FRIENDS THERE ARE THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
RECALCITRANT. IN STEPPING UP TO
DO THEIR PART. TO SOLVE THE
HOUSING CRISIS IN THIS BILL IF
NOTHING ELSE SENDS A MESSAGE TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT YOU CAN
RUN BUT YOU CAN'T HIDE AND
WE'RE ALL GOING TO HAVE TO STEP
UP. TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS NO COMMUNITY SHOULD BE
EXEMPT FRIENDS I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. CENTER DRAWS A- THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I TOO WANTED OUR
EXPRESS PUBLICLY MY
APPRECIATION FOR THE EFFORTS BY
SENATOR- WIENER FOR ALL OF HIS
VERY VERY HARD WORK BUT I WANT
TO EXPRESS MY CONCERNS WTH SB
FIFTY. ON AFFORDABILITY TEN IN
PROTECTIONS AND EXEMPTIONS. I
WANT TO SAY THAT. THE FIRST THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES HAS BEEN.
WORKING VERY VERY HARD IN
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT THE CITY
HAS TO PASS THE GOAL OF
BUILDING AT LEAST A HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNITS BY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWO YEARS EARLY. NOT
ENOUGH. NOT ENOUGH THAT TOOK A
LOT OF WORK. AND YET AS AS BE
FIFTY IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
COUNTIES WITH A POPULATION OF
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND OR LESS
WOULD BE EXEMPTED FROM THE SAME
RULES WITHOUT HAVING SHOWN HARD
WORK TO GET WHERE WE NEED TO
GET. THAT MEANS THAT FORTY
THREE OUT OF FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WILL BE EXEMPTED FROM
THE SAME REQUIREMENTS AS OTHERS.
NOW I RECOGNIZE. THE EFFORT TO
CREATE A PROCESS FOR EXEMPTIONS
YET WELL ANGELENOS DEDICATE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
TO HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. AND
OTHERS DO NOT HAVE TO LIVE UP
TO THE SAME STANDARDS I
UNDERSTAND THE SUPPLY SIDE OF
HOUSING PRODUCTION IS IMPORTANT
WE'VE GOT TO DO IT. BUT THEN I
SAY WHAT ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. LOS ANGELES IS
COMMITTED TO BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEAR TRANSIT
THE PROOF LIES IN A DECADE OF
ADVOCACY AND HARD WORK AND
COMPROMISE THIS LED TO NOVEMBER
TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN VOTERS
APPROVED MEASURE J. J. J. WHICH
CREATED THE TRANSIT ORIENTED
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM. THIS
PROGRAM INVOLVED IN INCLUDES
SKILLED LABOR STANDARDS LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS AND
ENSURING THAT HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT BRINGS ECONOMIC
BENEFITS TO OUR COMMUNITIES THE
TLC PROGRAM HAS PROPOSED
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS. ALMOST
FOUR THOUSAND OF THESE UNITS
WILL BE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
ACCORDING TO A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION STUDY SB
FIFTY WOULD ADD TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED HOUSING UNITS INCLUDING
APPROXIMATELY TEN. ON SITE
AFFORDABLE UNITS IN THE CITY
ABOUT LATE. SB FIFTY IT WOULD
ONLY ADD TEN NET NEW ON SITE
AFFORDABLE UNITS. WE ALSO
APPROVED A ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR BOND FOR SUPPORT
OF HOUSING AND HOUSING FOR
HOMELESS SB FIFTY WILL DISRUPT
OUR DECADE LONG PROCESS OF
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
NEAR TRANSIT IN LA. CAN I
PROTECTIONS ARE A TOP PRIORITY
FOR ME AND I KNOW FOR MANY OF
YOU. 77% OF RESIDENTS IN MY
DISTRICT ARE RENTERS. THE
HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF ANY
DISTRICT IN THE STATE. LAST
YEAR I PROPOSED SB FIVE TWENTY
NINE WHICH WOULD HAVE PROTECTED
AND STRENGTHENED TENANT
ASSOCIATIONS AND REQUIRED
EVICTIONS FOR JUST BECAUSE-
RICK A JUST CAUSE REDUCTIONS.
SB FIVE TWENTY NINE GOT TWENTY
BOATS AND DID NOT GO TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIS FIGHT ISN'T OVER
ALONG SEVERAL OF MY COLLEAGUES
WE ARE DETERMINED TO CONTINUE
ADVOCATING FOR REAL TEN AND
PROTECTIONS. AND THERE ARE
POINT DISTINCTIONS BETWEEN ANTI
DEMOLITION PROTECTIONS AND
TENANT PROTECTION. SB FIFTY
SETS ANTI DEMOLITION
PROTECTIONS. BUT DO NOT ADDRESS
PRE VACATIONS AND THE VACATIONS
UNDER THESE PROTECTIONS THE
BUILDING MIGHT BE PRESERVED FOR
A FEW MORE YEARS BUT EVICTIONS
ARE LIKELY TO OCCUR. TEN IN
PROTECTIONS FOCUSED ON KEEPING
FAMILIES IN THEIR HOMES FOR
GENERATIONS. IN ADDITION TO MY
BILL THERE ARE OTHER MODELS
PRETENDING PROTECTIONS SUCH AS
PROVIDING THE LEGAL ASSISTANCE
AND RELOCATION ASSISTANCE TO
RENTERS AND STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS PRETENDING COMPLAINT
CASES. LASTLY IN ORDER TO
ENFORCE THE ANTI DEMOLITION
PROTECTIONS IN SB FIFTY THE
STATE NEEDS TO CREATE A RENTAL
REGISTRY. LAST YEAR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS INTRODUCED AB
SEVEN TWO FOUR WHICH WOULD DO
JUST THAT. THIS BILL WAS HELD
IN COMMITTEE. SO EXCEPT FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE BILL ALL
TEN THE PROTECTION BILLS FAILED
LAST YEAR STRONG TENDED
PROTECTIONS ARE ESSENTIAL TO
ADDRESSING THE HOUSING CRISIS
WORLD TALKING ABOUT. IT IS MY
HOPE THAT WE ALL WORK HARDER TO
SHARE THE RESPONSIBILITY. OF
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
PROTECTING TENANTS. TO ME WE
ARE NOT CLOSE IN THIS BILL. I
WILL MANY TIMES FOR BILLS THAT
NEED IMPROVEMENT. BUT THE THREE
FUNDAMENTAL FLAWS I'VE TALKED
ABOUT HAVE NOT BEEN RESOLVED.
AND IF THIS BILL IS NOT THE
ANSWER. TO THE HOUSING CRISIS
THAT LET'S NOT PRETEND WE ARE
ADDRESSING ALL OF THE ISSUES
WITH CALL IT WHAT IT IS IT'S A
MARKET MARKET HOUSING
PRODUCTION BILL THANK YOU.
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT AND I
WANT TO STAND ON IN SUPPORT OF
A NUMBER OF THE ISSUES AND
CONCERNS RAISED BY MY FELLOW
COLLEAGUES FELLOW ANGELINOS. I
WANT TO STOP AND THINK THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL. FOR DOING A
YEOMAN'S JOB- OF TALKING TO ALL
OF US MANY OF US NUMEROUS TIMES
FOR COMING TO VISIT OUR
DISTRICTS UPON INVITATION HE
VISITED THE EIGHTH COUNCIL
DISTRICT- IN MY SENATE DISTRICT
AND SAT IN THE HOME. OF
HOMEOWNERS OUT CONSTITUENTS TO
REALLY HEAR FIRSTHAND THEIR
CONCERNS AND SO I THINK YOU. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK COMMUNITIES
NO NOT JUST OUR LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS OR INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS BUT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO. ORGANIZE
THEMSELVES AND EDUCATE
THEMSELVES AND READ THE- I
THINK FOR AMENDED VERSIONS OF
THIS BILL THE THREE AMENDED
VERSIONS OF ITS PREDECESSOR-
AND WHO ARE PAID TO DO THIS
WORK. BUT GALVANIZED NEIGHBORS
TO REALLY TALK AND EDUCATE
THEMSELVES AND EDUCATE US ABOUT
THE IMPACT THEY FEAR SUPPORT SB
FIFTY WOULD HAVE ON THEIR
COMMUNITY. FIVE I DON'T WANT TO
BE REPETITIVE. THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF ISSUES THAT I HAVE
NOT HEARD RAISING THE FLOOR
THAT I THINK ARE IMPORTANT. YOU
KNOW HOUSING POLICY IS NOT NEAR
CLEAN HOUSING POLICY. HAS BEEN
PLAGUED BY. RACIST HISTORIC
POLICIES. AND SELL THE
INTERSECTION OF RACE AND CLASS
HAS A MAJOR IMPACT ON HOUSING
POLICY IN THE STATE AND WE
CANNOT DENY THAT NOR CAN WE
OVER SIMPLIFY OUR CONVERSATION
ABOUT WE NEED HOUSING I WORK
FOR AN ORGANIZATION THAT- HAD
A- MONSTER THAT HARD WORK IS
EASY WORK NOT DONE A PROPER
TIME LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE FAILED
ALL OF US IN OUR RESIDENTS IN
TERMS OF NOT DOING THE PROPER
WORK RIGHT TIME IN TERMS BEEN
AGGRESSIVE IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE WE BUILD ADEQUATE HOUSING
FOR ALL ACROSS THE SOCIO
ECONOMIC SPECTRUM. I THINK IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE IN
MY DISTRICT SPECIFICALLY SOUTH
LA. SINGLE FAMILY HOMES DO
DOMINATE THE LANDSCAPE AND ARE
IN DIRECT CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
MAJOR TRANSIT ZONES THAT'S THE
REALITY OF PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
THE THIRTY TH DISTRICT. I THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO REMIT
RECOGNIZE THAT SINGLE FAMILY
HOMEOWNERS ARE NOT A MONOLITHIC
GROUP. THAT SAME COMMUNITY WAS
ALSO RAVAGED BY THE HOUSING
CRASH PRICES AND HAVE BEEN
SUBJECTED TO RED LINING AND
PAID FOR A HIGHER INTEREST
RATES FOR MORTGAGES IF THEY CAN
GET THEM. AND SO WE HAVE SINGLE
FAMILY HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE
HOLDING ON. BY THEIR
FINGERNAILS IN TERMS OF KEEPING
THOSE HOUSES AND SO AS WE DO
TALK ABOUT COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE DOMINATED A
DISPROPORTIONATE BURKE ENTERS.
SOME OF US REPRESENT
COMMUNITIES TO. DO HAVE
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE HOLDING ON
BY THE SKIN OF THEIR TEETH. WE
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THE
DIFFERENCE THE DIVERSITY OF THE
HOUSING. MARKET AND THOSE WHO
ARE IN IT. FOR ME THE CORE
ISSUE AS WE DEBATE THE HOUSING
CRISIS BECAUSE WE ARE IN ONE.
IS CAN BE SUMMED UP IN ONE
SENTENCE WHO HAS THE PRIVILEGE
OF LIVING WHERE. AND AS WE DO
CONFLATE ISSUES BECAUSE A WHOLE
LOT OF CONFLATION OF GOING ON
WITH REGARD TO SB FIFTY. THE
ISSUE OF GENTRIFICATION COMES
OUT RESOUNDINGLY IN MY
COMMUNITY. AND THE ISSUE OF
GENTRIFICATION IS SYNONYMOUS
WITH THE YEAR. EIGHT CORE FEAR
ABOUT CAN I AFFORD TO CONTINUE
TO LIVE IN MY COMMUNITY. WE'LL
DEVELOPERS AND SPECULATORS BY
UP THE PROPERTY AROUND ME AND
MAKE MY COMMUNITY LOOK AND FEEL
DIFFERENT. WHO WILL BE MY NEW
NEIGHBORS. FEAR AROUND ALL OF
THOSE CORE ISSUES. AND SO WE
CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOUSING POLICY ABSENT THE
REALITY OF WHAT PEOPLE ARE
FEELING IN THEIR OWN TOWNS AND
NEIGHBORHOODS. YOU KNOW I HAVE
BEEN DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE-
THANK YOU MISSED AUTHOR. UP
PRETTY CONSISTENTLY FOR ABOUT
THREE YEARS NOW WE DID A
CALCULATION THIS MORNING IN MY
OFFICE AND WE'VE BEEN INVITED
TO PARTICIPATE IT EITHER MYSELF
OR STAFF IT LITERALLY A DOZEN
CONVENIENCE. ENGAGING THOUSANDS
PLURAL OF RESIDENTS OF THE
THIRTY SENATE-DISTRICT THE TALK
ABOUT THIS ISSUE. AND I PUSH
BACK CARD I SAID IF NOT SB
FIFTY IF YOU SAY NOT SB FIFTY
WOULD YOU SAY YES TO. AND I
HAVE TO GIVE MY CONSTITUENTS
CREDIT BECAUSE THEY STEPPED UP
TO THE PLATE. AND WE HAVE LISTS
AND CHARTS- OF IDEAS MOST OF
WHICH I HAVE SHARED WITH THE
AUTHOR SOME OF WHICH HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN BILLS THAT WE'VE
PASSING CLEAN SB THREE THIRTY
WHICH I DID VOTE FOR. I WAS
HESITANT AND RIDICULE FOR IT
FOR NOT MAKING A PUBLIC
STATEMENT A WHERE I'D BE WITH
THE BILL A YEAR AGO. AND I
DIDN'T DO THAT BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. AND SO I DIDN'T GO
PUBLIC AGAIN NOT DIRECTLY TO
THE MEDIA BUT TO AT MY
COMMUNITY AT TOWN HALL THIS
WEEK ABOUT MY POSITION BECAUSE
I COULD THEN OPINE ON THE FINAL
VERSION OF THE BILL THAT I KNEW
WE WOULD BE VOTING ON TODAY.
AND SO THIS IS A PROCESS I GET
THAT. BUT AGAIN I HAVE TO
CONCUR WITH MANY OF THE ISSUES
RAISED BY MY COLLEAGUES ABOUT
WHY THIS IS IT. RIGHT FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF MY DISTRICT AT
THIS TIME. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
HAVE A BROADER CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW WE DIG OURSELVES OUT
OF THE HOUSING CRISIS WERE IN.
ZONING IS ONE KEY ISSUE
RECOGNIZING THE HISTORICAL
ROLES ONLY HAS PLAYED IN
KEEPING CERTAIN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY OUT OF CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES. AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THERE ARE MANY CITIES
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY WERE
ELIMINATING- EXCLUSIONARY
ZONING FOR THAT HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED. BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION IN A BROADER
CONTEXT WITH MULTIPLE OPTIONS
TO HELP. EVERYONE ACROSS THE
BOARD. IN TERMS OF
AFFORDABILITY. I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY I
WILL STAND UP AND SEND ALONG
SIDE MY COLLEAGUES AS WE
CONTINUE TO BRING FORWARD
EQUALLY AS CHALLENGING COMPLEX
MEASURES. TO ADDRESS NOT ONLY
THE ROOT CAUSES OF OUR CURRENT
HOUSING CRISIS BUT HOW WE WILL
LEAD CALIFORNIA IN BEGIN OUR
WAY OUT OF IT. CENTER DOLLY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I. RISE IN THE SUPPORT
THIS BILL I WANTED. SHARE MAYBE
A LITTLE DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
THAT I HAVEN'T HEARD YET SPOKEN
ABOUT HERE TODAY. I THINK THIS
IS A HEALTHY DEBATE I GIVE THE
AUTHOR A LOT OF CREDIT FOR
TACKLING THIS ISSUE THIS IS NOT
EASY. IT'S CONTROVERSIAL- BUT A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY BACKGROUND
SIXTEEN YEARS ON A BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS DOING GENERAL PLANS
AND HEARING COUNTLESS VERY WELL
EDUCATED PLANNERS ABOUT SMART
GROWTH AND ABOUT SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES. AND ABOUT ALL THE
REASONS WHY YOU SHOULD BUILD
WHERE YOU SHOULD BUILD TO MAKE
A SOCIETY- WORK IN A MANNER
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE A FOOT
PRINT ON THE LAND. AS HARSH AS
IT CAN BE IN SOME AREAS. AND
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF TESTIMONY
TODAY ABOUT. WAS SITTING IN
THEIR AUTOMOBILES FOR HOURS
MIGRATING TO AND FROM WORK. YOU
KNOW YOU ALL KNOW I FARM AND
ONE OF THE REASONS I GOT
INVOLVED IN. POLITICS AND RUN
FOR OFFICE WAS BECAUSE I SAW US
PAVING OVER OUR FARM LAND'S.
AND I THINK THAT'S WRONG I
THINK THERE'S BETTER PLACES THE
BILL DIDN'T ON OUR PURPOSE-
FERTILE SOILS AND WHERE WE HAVE
WATER TO GROW OUR CROPS. IT'S
SO TODAY I LOOK AT THIS BILL
AND I I'VE BEEN TOLD IN OUR
DISTRICT HOW TO MANAGE MY LAND
BY PEOPLE WHO DON'T MANAGE LAND
I'VE HEARD FROM PEOPLE IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY HOW TO
MANAGE OUR FEDERAL FORCED TO
DON'T LIVE. IN OUR FEDERAL
FOREST. AND WE'RE BURNING DOWN
AND WE SEE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
AREN'T RIGHT. NOW IF YOU LOOK
AT THIS BILL AND YOU LOOK AT
WHAT IT IS DESIGNED TO DO IS
DESIGNED TO PUT PEOPLE. WHERE
THEY WORK AND KEEP THEM. FROM
BUILDING IN OUR FARM LAND'S.
END BEIG SITTING IN CARS AND
DOING OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT AND
ARE SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY SO I
LOOK AT IT AND THAT TAXED. IS
IT PERFECT THERE'S NO BILL
THAT'S PERFECT IN THIS PLACE. I
HEARD TALK ABOUT THE WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE. DO YOU GET A
BILL EVERY HOME IN THE VALLEY
OF THIS STATE BECAUSE MOST OF
THE REST THE STATE AS WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE I HELD A MAP
BUT WE DID SB NINE A ONE. AND
IT'S READ ON EVERY SIDE EVEN
THE COAST MOST THE COAST EXCEPT
FOR THE VALLEY SO- BUT THIS
BILL I THINK MAKES SENSE I
THINK THE AUTHOR HAS DONE HIS
JOB I URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO-
GET THIS BILL OUT OF THIS HOUSE
OVER THE OTHER HOUSE AND LET'S
BUILD SOME HOMES WHERE WE
SHOULD BUILD OWNS. WHERE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT. I DRIVE IN
HIGHWAY FIFTY- SIT. OUT OF MY
DISTRICT AND I GO BY THE
HOSTESS. FACTORY THAT WE USED
TO GET A HOSTESS TWINKIES OUT
OF ITS SHUT DOWN RIGHT OUT OF
TOWN HERE. IT'S VACANT IT HAS
LIGHT RAIL RIGHT NEXT TO IT
IT'S BEEN PAVED OVER. THOSE ARE
PLACES WE SHOULD PUT HOMES. WE
HAVE A HOUSING SHORTAGE. I'M A
BELIEVER IN SUPPLY AND DEMAND
WORKS WHEN YOU DRIVE THE SUPPLY
UP THEY'LL BE LESS DEMAND AND
IT DRIVES ACOSTA DOWN. WE NEED
TO BUILD HOMES IN CALIFORNIA I
BELIEVE THIS IS. ONE OF THE
ANSWERS MANY OTHER ANSWERS OUT
THERE SO I WOULD URGE YOU TO
VOTE FOR THIS BILL I THINK THE
AUTHOR I THANK YOU FOR THE
DEBATE I KNOW IT'S NOT EASY.
BUT LET'S DO SOMETHING GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO MOVE THIS BILL
OUT. SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK
YOU AYE MADAM PRESIDENT A
MEMBERS AND I HAVE TO
COMPLIMENT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO FOR GIVING ME THE
BEST BIRTHDAY PRESENT I'VE EVER
GOTTEN- DISCUSSION OF SB FIFTY
ON MY FIFTY NINTH BIRTHDAY SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT- WE'RE BOTH
FROM NEW JERSEY WE HAVE A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP AND I HAVE
TREMENDOUS RESPECT FOR HIM- AND
I MUST RISE TO RESPECTFULLY-
DISAGREE AND OPPOSE SB FIFTY-
LAST YEAR WHEN I PUT THIS ON
THE TO YOUR BILL LIST- I DID
THAT ON PURPOSE IN ORDER NOT TO
STOP THE DEBATE. MY HOPE WAS
THAT OVER THE BREAK- WE COULD
ENGAGE PEOPLE IN A PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION- TO ADDRESS MANY
OF THE COMMENTS AND CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED TODAY-
THE FACT YOU HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE STANDING UP. EXPRESSING
VERY SIMILAR COMMENTS
UNDERSCORES THAT THESE ARE
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS- THAT WAS
MY HOPE- BECAUSE I LEARNED BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN. WHEN WE
HAD A DEDICATED FUNDING SOURCE
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING CALLED
REDEVELOPMENT. AND WE DISSOLVED
IT. AND AT THE TIME THERE WAS
TALK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE. WE'RE
GONNA DO SOMETHING BETTER.
WE'RE GOING TO IMPROVE THE
PROCESS WE'RE GONNA NOT FORGET
ABOUT FINDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND I SAID AT THE TIME.
DON'T DO AWAY WITH THIS PROGRAM
AND TO YOU ACTUALLY HAVE A
REPLACEMENT IN PLACE. SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO FUND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND EVERYBODY SAID
DON'T WORRY. WE'LL GET IT
RIGHT. JUST NOT TODAY. WELL
HERE WE ARE NEARLY A DECADE
LATER AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
JOSE AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HUMBOLDT AND I JOINTLY AUTHORED
SB FIVE. STILL TRYING TO
REPLACE THAT DEDICATED FUNDING
SOURCE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND HAD WE NOT DONE AWAY WITH
REDEVELOPMENT WE WOULD HAVE
PROBABLY HAD ABOUT TEN BILLION
DOLLARS SPENT. ON ACTUALLY
CONSTRUCTING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. SO I SHARE THAT. TO
UNDERSCORE OUR RESPONSIBILITY
TODAY TO GET IT RIGHT. BECAUSE
WE GOT IT WRONG A DECADE AGO
AND THAT'S WHY THIS IS A
CRITICAL CONVERSATION AND WHEN
I HEAR MY GOOD COLLEAGUES WHO I
RESPECT TREMENDOUSLY TALK ABOUT
WELL THIS WILL COME BACK TO US.
WELL IT'LL COME BACK TO US ON
CONCURRENCE WERE WILL ONLY HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO AN UPPER
DOWN VOTE WE WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY LOOK
AND DISCUSS. THE POLICY. IN THE
POLICY COMMITTEE ON THE MERITS
OF THOSE AMENDMENTS AND SO.
THAT'S WHY IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE TAKE THIS TIME AND I THINK
IT WAS THE MAJORITY LEADER WHO
MENTIONED. THIS BILL IF IT WERE
TO MOVE OUT OF THIS HOUSE TODAY.
WOULD STILL BE GOING THROUGH
THE SAME PROCESS F. OF ANOTHER
BILL WAS INTRODUCED SO. THE
URGENCY OF THE SITUATION. CRIES
OUT THAT WE ADDRESS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH URGENCY. BUT
THIS BILL DOESN'T DO THA. AND
BY PASSING IT ALONG A DOZEN
EXPEDITE THAT CONVERSATION IT
FRANKLY SHORT CHANGED IS THAT
CONVERSATION. IN THIS HOUSE THE
STATE SENATE AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS IT'S BEEN
RAISED WE HAVE AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS BUT YET IF YOU
DO TEN UNITS OR LOWER. THERE'S
NO AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT GETS
DONE WITH THIS BILL IF YOU DO
TWENTY UNITS TO TEN UNITS YOU
CAN PAINT TO A FINE AND NOT
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THAT'S AN EASILY SOLVABLE
CHANGE IN THIS BILL THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN DONE OVER THE LAST
SIX MONTHS BUT IT WASN'T SO
THAT BEGS THE QUESTION. WHY WHY
DIDN'T WE MAKE THIS BILL ABOUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT'S BEEN
ARGUED SUPPLY AND DEMAND AND
TRICKLE DOWN ARE VALID SERIES
WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST THAT
THEY HAVEN'T REALLY WORKED ALL
THAT MUCH THAT WELL- AND ONE
COULD ARGUE THAT IF YOU
INCREASE DENSITY YOUR
INCREASING LAND VALUE WHICH
INCREASES CONSTRUCTION COSTS
WHICH RAISES RENTS. IT DOESN'T
LOWER RENTS AND SO MUCH HAS
BEEN MADE ABOUT THE COMMUNITIES
IN THE PLACE AND THE
SPECULATION OF WHERE THE
OPPOSITION IS COMING FROM. AND
<c.cyan>RANKLY MOST OF THE COMMUNITIES</c>
THAT I HAVE BEEN HEARING FROM
HAVE BEEN IN MY GOOD SENATOR TO
MY LEFT. COMMUNITY AND MY SEAT
MATES COMMUNITY HARD WORKING
CLASS COMMUNITIES CLOSE TO
DOWNTOWN LA. AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LA TALK ABOUT WHO ARE IN
FEAR. OF DISPLACEMENT AND
GENTRIFICATION AND I THINK FOR
GOOD REASON WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS MY OTHER CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES MANSION. THIS IS
ABOUT MARKET RATE HOUSING.
THERE IS A LEGITIMATE FEAR IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES WITH.
ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS WITHOUT
SAYING THAT THESE HAVE TO BE
AFFORDABLE UNITS WITHOUT
PUTTING SERIOUS- CONTROLS ON
HOW MUCH THEY WOULD GO IN THAT
MARKET RATE PROPOSAL. THOSE ARE
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS AND SO I
BELIEVE MY COLLEAGUE SHOULD BE
COMMENDED BECAUSE THE OTHER
THING THAT'S BEING MENTIONED IS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
RESPONSIBILITY WELL I CHARGE
THE LA COUNTY LEAGUE AND ONE
GARZA THEIR PRESIDENT WHO LIVES
IN SENATOR ARCHER LET HIS
DISTRICT WITH COMING UP WITH
ALTERNATIVES. AND THEY ARE
INITIALLY CAME UP WITH THOSE
ALTERNATIVES AND THEY PUT THEM
ON THE TABLE AND THEY WANTED TO
GET TO YES SO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO. MOVED THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BAR FIRED THAN
ANYONE WOULD HAVE ANTICIPATED
AND I THINK WE SHOULD TAKE THAT
OUT JERRY. TO PUT IN PLACE THE
BILL THAT ACTUALLY PRESS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SHORTAGE AND
USE. OUR MISS GOVERNMENT TO BE
A PARTNER IN THIS CONVERSATION
VERSUS PASSING A BILL THAT HAS
BEEN. ADDED WITH ALL OF THE
FLAWS STERN. CALLING TICKETED
ONLY HAVE IT COME BACK TO THIS
ON CONCURRENCE WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE
TODAY. SENATOR MOORLACH. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I GUESS WE
CAN ALL CONCUR THAT THIS IS- A
BILL THAT HAS PROVIDED SOME
VERY GOOD- DEBATE- I'D LIKE TO
FOCUS ON PROPERTY RIGHTS- I WAS
CHALLENGE YESTERDAY WITH THE
QUESTION OF WHAT IS THE
CONSERVATIVE VIEW OF. BUILDING
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA AND- WE
ALWAYS SAY WELL IT'S A MATTER
SUPPLY WE SHOULD. LET THE
MARKET PROVIDE. A SUPPLY FOR
THOSE IN THE MARKETPLACE. SO IT
BROUGHT UP ALL KINDS OF
QUESTIONS ONE. SHOULD CERTAIN
REAL PROPERTY LOCATIONS BE
REPURPOSE FOR HIGHER DENSITY
HOUSING. IS THIS A FREE MARKET
OPPORTUNITY HAVE CITIES BEEN
TOO RESTRICTIVE IN THEIR ZONING
OR HAS CALIFORNIA BEEN THE
STRANGLEHOLD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT ARE ALSO KNOWN AS
C. QUIRK. WORSE YET IN MY
DISTRICT BEING COASTAL HAS THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
MAY BUILDING NEW HOUSING LESS
THAN A BREAK EVEN BUSINESS
PROPOSITION I HAVE ONE PROJECT
IN WEALTH STILL MY DISTRICT. IF
THEY WERE TRYING TO BUILD
HOUSING THE ENTIRE EIGHT YEARS
I WAS A SUPERVISOR. AND FIVE
YEARS LATER THEY'RE STILL NOT
ANY CLOSER. TO HAVE BEEN BUILT
ONE. STRUCTURE ON A PIECE OF
PROPERTY- SO ARE WE- IN THE WAY
OF ALLOWING THE MARKET TO
PROVIDE HOUSING. COLLEAGUES I
HAVE GONE OUT OF MY COMFORT
ZONE TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF SB
FIFTY THIS IS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE FOR ME
AND I HAVE A LOT OF GOOD
DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE I STRONGLY
BELIEVE IN LOCAL CONTROL. AND
SO I'VE HAD TO DEAL WITH THE
DEBATE OF WHAT IS LOCAL CONTROL.
SHOULD IT BE THE LANDOWNER.
SHOULD BE THE CITY COUNCIL THAT
HAS MORE CONTROL OR SHOULD IT
BE SACRAMENTO THAT HAS MORE
CONTROL AND SB FIFTY BROACHES
THESE THEMES. WE HAVE A HOUSING
CRISIS ALL AGREED BUT I BELIEVE
IT'S BEEN SELF INFLICTED BY THE
THIS INSTITUTION. BY THIS BODY
OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE. PASSED
BILLS THAT HAVE MADE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR WELL MEANING
DEVELOPERS AND ANY AND HERE WE
ARE SO. IS THIS THE BEST BILL
TO DO IT. NOW PROBABLY NOT IT
GOES AFTER EVERY CITY BUT WITH
LIMITED CARVE OUT AND I PREFER
A BETTER NO BETTER NO WORSE
APPROACH AND I HOPE AS IT GOES
TO THE ASSEMBLY BUT SHOULD-
THAT THEY MODIFY THE BILL TO
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THE MANY AMENDMENTS. SOME
CITIES ARE DOING WHAT WE WANT
TO BAIT SO WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO ENCOURAGE THESE THAT
HAVE BEEN ADDING NEW HOUSING AT
THE LIBERTY OF FASHION AND
MAYBE GO A LITTLE STRONGER ON
THE BAD ACTORS I THINK THE BILL
ALSO NEEDS TO MORE CLEARLY
DEFINED JOB RICH AREAS I AND
BOUNDARIES AND I THINK
UNLIMITED DENSITY IS OPAQUE AND
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
ABOUT THIS COULD BE REFINED
GOING FORWARD. PARKING
LIMITATIONS NEED MORE
CLARIFICATION IS THE RULE OF
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WHICH
HAS ALREADY BEEN REFERRED TO
SHOULD NOT COME INTO PLAY TO
CREATE EVEN MORE PROBLEMS FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES I THINK A
SERIOUS REVIEW ALSO SHOULD BE
DONE. ON PUBLIC TRANSIT. IT IT
USAGE IS DECLINING AND WHEN AN
ORANGE COUNTY WHEN WE RAISE OUR
RATES BECAUSE YOU CAN ONLY
SUBSIDIZE 80% OF THE COST OF
PROVIDING A BUS FLEET THAT WHEN
YOU RAISE THE RATES THE
RIDERSHIP GOES DOWN AND IT GETS
CIRCULAR YOU KNOW THEN YOU GOT
TO RAISE IT AGAIN AND THEN IT
JUST IT JUST GETS ALL BENT OUT
OF SHAPE SO I THINK THIS
VICIOUS CYCLE WE NEED TO TAKE A
SERIOUS LOOK. AT MASS TRANSIT
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAS FAILED
TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR CARS.
BECAUSE THE CARS ARE DEPENDABLE.
EN MASS TRANSIT IS NOT AND SO
WE SHOULD NOT BE SURPRISED THAT
THAT THAT'S THE CASE AND SO
THAT NEEDS A HARD LOOK SB FIFTY
SHOULD CAUSE US TO REFLECT ON
THE GRAND SCHEME WHICH HAS BEEN
MENTIONED BY SEVERAL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WHAT'S IN PLACE NOW
IS NOT WORKING OPTIMALLY AND
MAY BECOME EVEN GREATER SINK
HOLES IN THE FUTURE AS OUR
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES.
LITERALLY GO BANKRUPT TRYING TO
DO SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
WORKING INTEGRATION WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
GUESS CAPACITY NEEDS TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE DISCUSSION MORE
HOUSING EQUALS MORE CHILDREN.
FOR CITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
HOMELESS SHELTERS. THEY SHOULD
BE REWARDED WITH SOME KIND OF
OFFSETS- IN THAT PROVIDE SOME
KIND OF BALANCE. AFTER DECADES
OF BENIGN NEGLECT SB FIFTY
PROVIDES A MASSIVE CULTURAL
CHANGE. THIS GROUND SHAKING WAS
PROBABLY LONG IN COMING. BUT
THE REVERBERATIONS ARE
DISTURBING THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
PROACTIVE IN THEIR LAND
PLANNING AND GENERAL PLAN
IMPLEMENTATIONS. CALIFORNIA
MADE SOME SHAKING UP MADAM
PRESIDENT. AT ALL LEVELS HERE
AND DOWN TO THE CITY LEVEL I
BELIEVE DISCUSSION MUST BE HAD
AND MUST BE CONTINUED. BUT IT
SHOULD BE BY A STRONG VOTE
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. I
DON'T WANT TO REITERATE WHAT
EVERYONE HERE SAD BUT THE ONE
THING I DO KNOW IS THAT I
BELIEVE THAT EVERYONE IS RIGHT
DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY COME
FROM WE ARE CAST OUT BY NóI IN
OUR OWN COMMUNITIES AND WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE. AND I THINK IT
REALLY DOES BLOW IT BOILED DOWN
TO OUR OWN COMMUNITIES
ECONOMICS DEMOGRAPHICS
EVERYTHING THAT THAT REALLY
SHAPES OUR OWN AREAS FOR
EXAMPLE. I WANT TO ALSO AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM LOS
ANGELES BOTH OF THEM THAT- IN
OUR AREA LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THERE HAVE BEEN SO MANY PEOPLE
THAT HAVE JUST PLEASE IN MY- IN
THE COMMUNITY. CORRUPT IN. HOME
ARE OVER HOUSING IS OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS I COULD NEVER
AFFORD THAT WE WERE DISPLACED
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
TAKE VERY PERSONALLY OUR FIRST
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT HE'S BEEN
WORKING REALLY HARD ON THIS
ISSUE AND TAKEN A LOT OF TME
TO LISTEN TO OUR CONCERNS AND
TRY TO SOLVE OUR CONCERNS. THIS
LAST WEEK I GATHERED MY TEEN
CITIES TO HEAR HIS CONCERNS AND
HE TOOK THE TIME TO ANSWER EACH
AND EVERYONE OTHER QUESTIONS
AND SO I BELIEVE THAT THAT HE
IS STATE TO TRY MAKE THIS BILL
BETTER. TO TRY TO HELP OUT BUT-
IN MY COMMUNITY LAST YEAR I
PASSED HOUSING. AND I PROMISE
MY COMMUNITIES THAT IF THEY
CAME TO THE TABLE AND HELP ME
SOLVE THE HOUSING CRISIS. THAT
WE COULD DO THIS. TOGETHER
BASED ON OUR OWN CIRCUMSTANCE
AND BASED ON OUR OWN
COMMUNITIES AND THE DATE THAT I
PASSED THE BILL LAST YEAR. AND
WE ARE ACTIVELY CRATE ACTIVELY
ENGAGED ON WHAT THAT'S GOING TO
LOOK LIKE SO I CAN PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR BUILDING HOMES.
PARTICULAR LOW INCOME HOUSING
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I DISCUSSED EARLIER IS THAT LOW
INCOME AFFORDABILITY MEANS
DIFFERENT THINGS TO DIFFERENT
PEOPLE. THE AVERAGE INCOME IN
ONE OF MY COMMUNITY SAYS FORTY
SEVEN THOUSAND. LOS ANGELES I
BELIEVE IT'S SIXTY FOUR
THOUSAND. CALIFORNIA OVER
SEVENTY THOUSAND. SO EVERYONE
HAS A DIFFERENT PERCEPTION OF
WHAT THAT MEANS AND IN MY
COMMUNITY. IT'S REALLY THE FEAR
THAT- MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
SANTA LEAST TALKED ABOUT. HOW
DO WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
GONNA GET DOES PLEASE I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT IF ONE SIZE FITS
ALL I DON'T BELIEVE THAT WHEN
WE BUILD HOUSES. IT'S GOING TO
MEAN THE SAME THING FOR
EVERYONE. AND IN MY COMMUNITIES
ONLY TAKE THE TIME TO TALK
ABOUT THE CITIES WE'VE BEEN
HEARING OFTEN OVER AND OVER
AGAIN THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO
HELP IN THAT WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE NEED TO COME
TO THE TABLE. WELL I CAN TELL
YOU WITH CERTAINTY MY FIFTEEN
COMMUNITIES DID COME TO THE
TABLE. THEY DID WORK ON THE ON
THE HOUSING TRUST AND THEY'RE
ACTIVELY PUTTING FUNDING NOT
TRUST TO TRY AND SOLVE THE
HOUSING CRISIS. SO FOR ME- NOT
ALL THE ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED
AND I WANT TO GIVE MY COMMUNITY
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
THAT HOUSING TRUST. AND IT'S
NOT IT HELLO. I STILL WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS. BUT
AFTER MEETING WITH THE WITH THE
AUTHOR I COMMUNITIES WITHIN
QUIET AND- AN AGREEMENT AT WHEN
I CAN AT THE- MOVE TOWARD I
JUST HAD THIS POINT I NEED TO.
WORK WITH MY COMMUNITY SINCE
THE POWER HAS. BEEN TOUCHED
WORKS THANK YOU. JUST PRESIDENT
I I'D LIKE THANK OF THE COM
THAT WERE OUT TO READ BY THE
CENTER FOR MOST. WE ALL COME
FROM DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES WE
ALL DIFFERENT PRIORITIES
DIFFERENT SENSIBILITIES
DIFFERENT DEMOGRAPHICS AND NOT
ONE IS MORE RIGHT THAN THE
OTHER. AND I THINK THIS IS A
FANTASTIC EXAMPLE OF DEMOCRACY
IN ACTION IN THE PUREST FORM.
WE AVE ONE PARTY SPLIT THE
OTHER FRACTURED AS WELL. AND TO
ME I THINK THIS IS A FANTASTIC
IDEA THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY DEBATE AN ISSUE ON
THE MERITS AN INTERNIST SO I'D
LIKE TAKE VENGEANCE OPPORTUNITY
IN COMMAND TO THE CENTER FROM
LOS FROM MY SAN FRANCISCO. FOR
MEETING WITH ME TALKING WITH ME
MEETING FRANKLY WITH EVERYBODY
AND BEING OPEN TO THE
AMENDMENTS TO TRY TO MAKE THIS
A BETTER PRODUCT. I DON'T THINK
WE'RE THERE YET. AND I WANT TO
I WANT TO GET AT LEAST EXPLAIN
JUST A LITTLE BIT ON WINE. SO
THE CELTS WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
SITUATION HERE WHERE WE HAVE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH. AND
IN SOME INSTANCES I THINK THAT
CAN WORK WHEN IT COMES TO
HOUSING HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
AND- AND POPULATION
DISPLACEMENT IT CLEARLY
DOESN'T. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I PUT FORWARD TO THE AUTHOR OF
THIS PIECE LEGISLATION IS.
MAYBE WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS A
LITTLE BIT WRONG. MAYBE A
BETTER APPROACH MIGHT BE TO
LOOK UPON IT WITH THE
CALCULATION RATIO. MEANING THAT
THE AREAS THAT HAVE THE MOST
HOUSING NEEDS BECAUSE NOT ALL
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA ARE EQUAL
IN THAT WERE IN THAT REGARD
THAT WE HAVE A CALCULATION
BASED RATIO. ON NEEDS THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK COULD BE
TERRIBLY HELPFUL- BUT NOW WE
ARE WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW AT
THE END OF A- THE CARRY OVER
FROM LAST YEAR AND MOVING INTO
THE NEW LEGISLATIVE CYCLE. I
DON'T VIEW TODAY'S VOTE AS THE
END OF THIS ISSUE IN FACT I
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
ENCOURAGE THIS TO BE SHOULD NOT
PASSED TODAY AND I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THE VOTES MAY MAY LIE ON
THIS. BUT I'M HOPING THAT THE
AUTHOR IF IT WERE NOT TO PASSED
TODAY SIMPLY REINTRODUCE IT SO
THAT WE CAN AGAIN- BRING IN
MORE STAKEHOLDERS AND I THINK
GET A CLOSER LOOK AT WHAT OTHER
OPTIONS MIGHT EXIST. FROM THE
VALLEY PERSPECTIVE I REPRESENT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND REBEKAH
REPRESENT ELEVEN COUNTIES. NOW
THE COUNTIES UP NORTH. DON'T
SEEM TO BE AS A AS AFFECTED AS
THE COUNTIES. IN THE SELF. AND
SO I HAVE ALL SORTS OF
DIFFERENT- PEOPLE TALKING TO
MIGHT YEAR OVER THE LAST.
NUMBER OF WEEKS ON WHAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE HAPPEN. THERE
IS NO CONCURRENCE. THE ONLY
THING THAT. FOLKS AGREE ON IS
THAT WE NEED HOUSING. HOW WE
GET THERE EVERYONE HAS A
DIFFERENT HAS A DIFFERENT
THEORY. AND ALL. TO BE FAIR TO
THE FOLKS THAT I REPRESENT I
REACH OUT TO A NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT. AND
I RECEIVED- WAS REALLY GOT THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
OPPOSITION TO THIS. I GOT CITY
OF CLOVIS IS OPPOSITION TO THIS
AND- MY FORMER. POLITICAL
POSITION. IN MY FOR POLITICAL
POSITION I GOT A LETTER FROM
THE FOR FROM FRESNO COUNTING IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS. SO THAT
PUTS ME IN A PRETTY INTERESTING
SITUATION WHERE- SO MY LARGEST
CONSTITUENCIES ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS. AND I HAVE TO ASK WHY. NO
I DON'T ALWAYS AGREE WITH WHAT
THE ANSWERS THAT I'VE BEEN
GIVEN IN FACT I THINK THERE IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE MUST PURSUE
BUT ONE GLARING REALITY IS
THAT. ANY IMPOSITION ON IN IN
THE HOUSING REALM WILL EXPAND
ELSEWHERE INTO THE NEIGHBORING
COUNTIES THE NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES US NOT ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISHING WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE SO MY POINT IN ALL THIS IS
THAT. I WOULD LIKE THIS TO
CONTINUE TO BE RE INTRODUCE. AS
SOON AS TOMORROW IT SHOULD IT
NOT PASSED TODAY SO THAT WE CAN
LOOK AT WHAT WHATEVER.
CALCULATION CAN BE ALLOWED WITH
THIS TYPE OF ONE SIZE FITS ALL
BECAUSE THIS NOTION OF LOCAL
CONTROL. IS LOCAL CONTROL IF
YOU IT HERE AND AGREE WITH
WITH- SACRAMENTO'S VISION. AND
THAT'S MY PROBLEM IS I DON'T
THINK THE LOCAL CONTROL IS TRUE
BUT IT CAN BE AND I WANT TO BE
SUPPORTIVE AND I THINK- THE
CENTER FROM SAN FRANCISCO'S
DONE AN EXEMPLARY JOB OF
PUSHING THIS ISSUE. I WON IT
PUSHED EVEN FURTHER AND I
BELIEVE THAT ALL THE FOLKS THAT
ARE BEHIND THIS. THE FOLKS IN
THE INDUSTRY. IN THE WE CANNOT
AFFORD ARE ON THE RIGHT TRACK I
THINK WE'RE ALMOST THERE I JUST
DON'T THINK WE'RE THERE YET.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHORS WELCOME SAN
FRANCISCO FORCE HARD WORK- HIS
DEDICATION TO THIS ISSUE AND
MEETING WOULD PROBABLY ALL OF
HIS COLLEAGUES AND TRYING TO
WORK OUT A ISSUE THAT IS NEAR
AND DEAR TO ALL OF US OF HOW DO
WE- ADDRESS. A HOUSING CRISIS
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND IN
MANY WAYS A SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE STATED A-
CRISIS THAT WAS. EXACERBATED BY
FOLKS LIKE MYSELF IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHO VOTED AND- NINE
YEARS AGO IN REDEVELOPMENT A
TOOL THAT HOPED TO BUILD REAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN MY
CHALLENGE WITH THIS BILL IS
THAT. AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
REALLY NOT BEING BUILT HERE THE
END INTENT IS THERE BUT THE
MECHANISM OF HOW DO WE GET
THERE THAT'S MY BIGGEST CONCERN
BECAUSE IT IS ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY I'VE TALKED TO.
WORKING FOLKS PEOPLE WHO MAKE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IN NAY
STEEL CAN AFFORD TO BUY A HOUSE
IN CALIFORNIA I TALKED TO ONE
INDIVIDUAL SAYS I HAVE TWO
CHOICES ONE LOOKING FOR THE
HOUSE. I'M LOOKING FOR THE
WORST HOUSE ON THE BEST BLOCK.
OR THE BEST HOUSE ON THE WORST
BLOCK. AND THAT'S ALL I CAN
AFFORD AND THAT'S ALL THE SHOW
ME AND WE NEED TO CHANGE THAT.
AND WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT
ZONING ZONING IT'S WHAT I LIKE
THE MOST ABOUT THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE SENATORS RIDER WE
KNOW THE HISTORY OF OUR ONE IT
WAS RACES AND HIS
IMPLEMENTATION IT WAS A DIRECT
RESULT OF BLACK LAWYERS SUING.
REGARD RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
AND COMMUNITIES RESPONDED WHAT
ARE ONE ZONING IT WAS AT AFTER
AN AMERICAN LEGISLATOR HERE IN
THIS VERY BODY BYRON ONE BIRD
WHO CAME UP WITH THE FAIR
HOUSING ACT IN RESPONSE TO THIS
DISCRIMINATORY ARE ONE ZONING.
THERE ARE COMMUNITIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ALL ONE ZONING STATE
ONE HOUSE PER ACRE. ONE HOUSE
PER ACRE HOW'S THAT
INCLUSIONARY IS EXCLUSIONARY
SO. THE ALL ONE NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED I'M YOU'RE COMMITTED
TO WORK ON THAT AREA
AFFORDABILITY WE HAVE TO CHANGE
THE PARADIGM OF UNDERSTANDING
WORKING CLASS FOLKS CAN'T
AFFORD HOUSING WE GOT TO CHANGE
THE PARADIGM THAT. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS. LOWER QUALITY AND
YOU'RE ONLY GOING TO ATTRACT
BLOCKING MINORITIES AS DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING STATED THE
MOBILITY FOR THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN IN THE SIXTIES WITH
WHAT FROM ONE SMALL GET OLD TO
A BIGGER GET ALL WE NEED TO-
FOR MAKE HOUSING AFFORDABLE FOR
ALL FOLKS TO LOOK- REACHED
AMERICAN DREAM SO I STAND
COMMITTED TO WORKING TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. CENTER
LEYVA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
REALLY IT'S VERY I HAVE ENJOYED
HEARING FROM EVERYONE AND I
JUST BEFORE I BEGIN MY COMMENTS
I WANT TO SAY THAT MIRACLES DO
HAPPEN I NEVER THOUGHT THAT THE
SENATOR FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND
I WOULD ACTUALLY AGREE ON
SOMETHING SO THERE'S A FIRST
FOR EVERYTHING. MEMBERS AGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR THAT THERE ARE
THERE'S A LOT OF MISINFORMATION
ABOUT SB FIFTY OUT THERE I'M
SURE MANY OF YOU ARE LIKE ME IN
YOUR TWITTER FEED IS BLOWING UP
AND YOU WANT TO RESPOND BACK
AND SAY READ THE BILL THAT'S
NOT WHAT IT SAYS. HOWEVER
MEMBERS ONE THING IS CLEAR WE
DO HAVE MORE TO DO TO FIX THE
HOUSING CRISIS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE STATUS QUO IS
SIMPLY NOT ENOUH THERE ARE
OTHER PROPOSALS BEFORE US IN
THE LEGISLATURE. BUT TODAY SB
FIFTY IS THE BILL BEFORE US
MEMBERS I'VE LISTENED TO
ARGUMENTS FROM THE PROPONENTS
THAT THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. I HAVE ALSO
LISTEN TO THE CONCERNS FROM
CITIES ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS AND LEADERS
PARTICULARLY SINCE THE AUTHOR
TOOK AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
EARLY THERE THIS MONTH. TO
OFFER MORE LOCAL CONTROL. THE
EVERY COMMUNITY A COUNTY IS
DIFFERENT THE PROBLEM IS
CLEARLY STATEWIDE. LOCALITIES
HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
STEP UP AND MAKE THE NECESSARY
CHANGES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
HELP GROW AFFORDABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE HOUSING. IN THEIR
OWN COMMUNITIES AND REGION. AND
QUITE HONESTLY IT JUST HASN'T
HAPPENED AND I SEE A LOT TO MY
CITIES IN MY COUNTIES. DON'T
WAIT FOR US TO DO IT FIX IT AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE YOU
MIGHT NOT LIKE WHAT WE COME UP
WITH. SB FIFTY GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION TODAY.
MADAM PRESIDENT I WAS ONE IF I
COULD ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS OF
THE AUTHOR. THE QUESTIONS. THAT
OBJECTION. THANK YOU UGH TEN A
PROTECTIONS THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT IS A BIG CONCERN TO ME AND
I THINK IT IS A CONCERN TO
OTHERS I THINK THAT THE TEN A
PROTECTIONS THAT WE HAVE NOW
UNDER STATE LAW ALLOW
DEVELOPERS TO COME IN UNDER THE
ELLIS ACT IN JUST BULLDOZE-
OKAY A DEVELOPMENT AND BUILD
WILL THIS BILL HELPS THAT IS IT
BETTER IS IT STRONGER OR NOT. I
SURE- THROUGH THE PRESIDENT I
THANK YOU AS CENTER FOR THAT- A
QUESTION- I TOUCHED ON THIS
EARLIER BUT I WANT TO REITERATE
BECAUSE EVER SINCE STATEMENTS
MADE ABOUT- RENT TO PROTECTIONS
ON SB FIFTY HAS THE STRONGEST
RENTER PROTECTIONS IN EXISTENCE
UNDER STATE LAW- IF A RENTER'S
LIVED ON THE PROPERTY AT ANY
POINT IN THE LAST SEVEN YEARS
OR OF AN ALICE ACTIVATION HAS
HAPPENED AT ANY POINT IN THE
LAST FIFTEEN YEARS YOU CANNOT
DEMOLISH THE BUILDING FOR AN SB
FIFTY- PROJECT. THIS IS
STRONGER THAN THE VAST MAJORITY
OF CITIES- HAVE IN TERMS OF
PROTECTIONS STRONGER THE VAST
MAJORITY CITIES IN CALIFORNIA I
DO WANT TO- WHICH IS NO BECAUSE
THERE'S BEEN SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES-
AND I WANT TO RESPOND TO THAT
SPECIFIC TO THIS ISSUE THERE
ARE OTHER ISSUES AS WELL. THESE
RENTER PROTECT. THE DEMOLITION.
SB ARE STRONGER THAN THE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE BY THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES STRONGER.
SO I DON'T THINK IT'S ACCURATE
TO SUGGEST THAT THIS BILL WILL
SOMEHOW MAKE IT EASIER TO
OBJECTS. TENANTS WERE
DEMOLISHED BUILDINGS IN LOS
ANGELES THIS WILL MAKE IT.
HARDER BY IN ADDITION- I WILL
NOTE THAT WE TALKED ABOUT- THE
TRANSIT ORIENTED COMMUNITIES OR
TOC PROGRAM IN LOS ANGELES
WHERE IT WAS UP SO ON. HER
VOTER INITIATIVE IT'S A
MINORITY OF THE CITY
GEOGRAPHICALLY BUT IT'S A VERY
EXCELLENT EXCELLENT PROGRAM-
AND IN FACT IT'S SO EXCELLENT
AND SO ROBUST- DIE WE- IT'S
EFFECTIVELY EXEMPTED FROM THIS
BILL. BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
ACTUALLY MORE OF ZONING THAT SB
FIFTY DOLLARS AND SO IT'S NOT
ACCURATE THAT THIS BILL WILL
DELAY ANYTHING INTO YOUR SEE.
AN ALLY. BY NOTE HOWEVER. THERE
ARE APPARENTLY QUITE A FEW
PROJECTS BUILT UNDER TOC IN LOS
ANGELES. AT RESULTS FROM ELLIS
OF BUILDING AND THEN TEARING IT
DOWN TO BUILD A BIGGER BILL.
I'M NOT EXISTING T. T. S. FIFTY
WOULD NOT ALLOW THAT WE GO
BEYOND. THOSE TEN PROTECTIONS.
STRONG TO REDUCTIONS IN WITH
THAT SAID WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH RENTS ARE ADVOCATES-
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYTHING IS
THERE TO SAY. AND I WILL JUST
END BY SAYING. I SUPPORT THE
RENT REGISTRY. THAT SOMEONE
NUMBER WICKS AUTHORED IRISH'S
REINTRODUCE. SHE'S THE PUBLIC I
THOUGHT- JUMPING ON FOR HER I
DON'T THINK IT'S INTO LAW I AND
I'M ASSIST. THE BILL'S BECAUSE
I WAS THE ME I AM COMMITTED TO
THIS ISSUE AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING ON A FURTHER. THANK
YOU THAT WAS VERY HELPFUL TO
HEAR THAT THE TEN A PROTECTIONS
WOULD ACTUALLY BE STRONGER.
UNDER SB FIFTY. OTHER QUESTION
I HAVE IS ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING I'VE HEARD A LOT OF
THAT I THINK IT'S A HUGE
CONCERN FOR EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
US. ON THIS FLOOR I HAVE MET
WITH THE VERBAL PURRS AND I'VE
ASKED THEM WHY THEY DON'T
DEVELOP MORE. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND THE WHOLE ME THAT
THEY DO THEY DON'T IT'LL BE. UP
MY ANY MONEY OFF OF IT. IN SB
FIVE. IF I'M READING CORRECTLY.
1720% WHAT IS BILL. MUST BE OF
HOW. WITHOUT SB FIFTY ARE THERE
ANY OTHER REGULATIONS. IN STATE
LAW RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
REQUIRING DEVELOPERS TO BUILD
IN THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT
ALL. ON SO- IT SB FIFTY- WILL-
I HAD I THINK THE STRONGEST
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS
UNDER STATE LAW. AND IN FACT
UNLIKE THE STATE DENSITY BONUS
WHICH IS EXISTING LAW WHICH
ALLOWS FOR MODERATE LOW INCOME
IN VERY LOW INCOME. SB FIFTY
FOR THE FIRST TIME ALSO
INCLUDES AN OPTION FOR
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME. WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY EITHER FORMALLY
HOMELESS PEOPLE OR PEOPLE
LIVING ON SSI CHECK- CHECKS TO
THE POOREST OF THE POOR SO WE
ARE BREAKING SOME NEW GROUND.
IN TERMS OF STATE AFFORDABILITY
LEVELS- IN THIS LAW- HI. ANY
CITY THAT HAS AN INCLUSIONARY
ORDINANCE. IF YOU KNOW HOW%
PARCELS OF WORDS OWNS A SINGLE
FAMILY WHICH WERE NOT SUBJECT
TO ANY AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE NOW IS ON
MULTI UNITS. YOU YOU MULTI UNIT
WILL TRIGGER THE AFFORDABILITY
AND LEAD TO MORE AFFORDABLE
UNITS- AND TALK TO SAN
FRANCISCO PLANNING DEPARTMENT
DID A STUDY. I CONCLUDED THAT
SB FIFTY WILL AND READY TO A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
AFFORDABLE UNITS THAT IS TRUE
IN ANY CITY- WITH INCLUSIONARY.
OF NO ALSO SPECIFIC TO THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES CA SEVERAL
DIFFERENT COMMENTS HAVE BEEN
MADE ABOUT THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. CURRENTLY 75% OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES. ZONE IN A
WEB. WERE AFFORDABLE. BANDS YOU
CAN'T BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN THE SEVENTY FIVE CENT OF
SOUNDS LISTA CITY. THAT IT
DAWNED ON PERCENT FAMILY. NAME
IS TRUE SEVEN SEC. I SENT.
THIRTY SO WE'RE IN THIS TO. BY
AND SAN FRANCISCO. I HEARD
ENOUGH ABOUT. AT THE WALL THE
REASON WHY FIVE HUNDRED YEAR
TOTAL. TEN OF THEM BEFORE I
WOULD I DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT
IT CAME. RESPECTFULLY IS NOT.
IT WILL BE A TO. HIGHER NOT
THAN NOT. AND IT IN THE SO OF
LOS. AL OF THE TO USE AREA ALSO
IN THE BOOK OF LOS ANGELES
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT TO DO
ANY ON SITE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OUTSIDE OF THE TOC AREA.
THERE'S ANOTHER THERE'S A
LINKAGE FEE THAT YOU PAY.
LINCOLN CHAFEE BUT THERE'S NO
ONSITE REQUIRED AND SO FOR
THERE TO BE CRITICISM OF SB
FIFTY BECAUSE WE MANDATE ON
SITE AFFORDABLE FOR TWENTY
UNITS ARE MORE. BUT FOR A LEAD
IN THE TWENTY UNITS- WOULD PAY
A FEE. SB FIFTY GOES BEYOND THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES
DRAMATICALLY IN TERMS OF
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS IN
THE LARGE MAJORITY OF THAT
CITY- AND WILL INCREASE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH IS WHY
SO MANY NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUILDERS. THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR THEIR ONLY JOB IS TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE- AND FORMALLY
HOMELESS PEOPLE NOT ALL OF THEM
ARE SUPPORTING THIS BILL BUT
MANY. OF THEM ARE AND THEN
FINALLY WE GOT A REQUEST FOR AN
AMENDMENT FROM AN ORGANIZATION
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CALLED THE QUEEN OF BEAUTIFUL
AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUP-
TO- HELP MAKE SURE THAT A CHUNK
OF THE AFFORDABLE UNITS
PRODUCED UNDER THIS BILL. WOULD
BE- PRIORITIZE FOR LOCAL
RESIDENTS TO THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN A COMMUNITY CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO WHAT'S BEING BUILT
THERE WE MADE THAT AMENDMENT.
40% OF THE UNITS THERE IS A
PREFERENCE- FOR LOCAL
RESIDENTS- AND I THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE- OF
THE BILL SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT IS FOR
HELPFUL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS NONE OF US
CAME HERE TO DO THE EASY WORK
WE ALL CAME HERE TO DO THE HARD
WORK AND I WOULD PUT THIS IN
THE CATEGORY OF HARD WORK. I
STAND HERE BEFORE YOU IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WITH ALL A
LEVIN OF MY CITIES IN
OPPOSITION. SO I WILL HAVE
EXPLAINING TO DO WHEN I GO BACK
HOME BUT I THINK WHEN I SIT
DOWN AND TALK TO THE OUR CITIES
MY CITIES. THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND AND
I HOPE THAT I CAN HELP THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THAT. I THINK IT'S
EASY TO PICK WINNERS AND LOSERS
BUT WHAT'S REALLY DIFFICULT IS
TO FIND A BILL OR FIND
SOMETHING WHERE EVERYBODY'S A
LITTLE HAPPY. THERE WAS A
LITTLE UNHAPPY I THINK RIGHT
NOW THIS BILL IS SB FIFTY. IF
IT GETS OFF THE FLOOR TODAY
THERE CERTAINLY MORE WORK THAT
WILL BE DONE. I WOULD IMPLORE
EVERYONE HERE TODAY TO GIVE GO
UP ON THE BILL FOR THE BILL
GETS OUT OF THE HOUSE WE CAN DO
SOME MORE WORK ON IT. I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR I THANK
YOU FOR EVERYTHING OU'VE DONE
AND I THINK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR ALL OF THEIR
COMMENTS CONCERNS. THIS IS THE
MOST PRESSING ISSUE WITH NO FOR
EVERYONE IN THE STATE FOR YOU.
CAME OUT OF. I REGION I HAVE.
SENATOR ALAN. MEMBERS CERTAINLY
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR THIS
ROBUST DISCUSSION- I DO ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THE AUTHOR IS HELP
TO SHIFT THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE NEED FOR HOUSING AND I'VE
I'VE SEEN AS A RESULT- MEMBERS
OF MY OWN LOCAL COMMUNITY
TALKING ABOUT SOLUTIONS AND
THAT THEY WOULD NOT HAVE
CONSIDERED SEVERAL YEARS
EARLIER AND I THINK YOU SEEN
SOME AGGRESSIVE BUT CERTAINLY
INADEQUATE LEGISLATION PASSED
OUT OF THIS HOUSE- BECAUSE OF
HIS EFFORTS- I CONTINUE TO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
THAT I AND I APPRECIATE THE
CALL IF WE THAT WE JUST. HEARD
ABOUT AFFORDABILITY BUT I THINK
ONE THE CONCERN WE HAVE ABOUT
THE BILL AS IT IS AND WHEN THE
REASONS WHY SO MANY OF THE
TENANTS GROUPS AND THE AND YOU
KNOW THE AB THE POVERTY
ADVOCATES AND A POVERTY
ADVOCATES ARE ARE SO CONTINUE
TO BE SO CONCERNED THE BILL IS
DIED IN YET TODAY EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT YOU TALK ABOUT. FARM 48%
OF AVERAGE ME INCOME. IT DOES
OFFER PROOF. FOR GOING LOWER-
BUT IN THE END OF THE DAY THOSE
POSTS PROVISIONS ARE OPTIONAL.
AND SO- YEAH I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S BEEN A LITTLE LOST IN IN
SOME OF THE DISCUSSION. I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
DIFFERENT CITIES WITH VARYING
LEVELS OF EFFORT- AND THE BILL
DOES NOT. ADEQUATELY PROVIDE
FOR DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO
THOSE DIFFERENT CITIES IN THEIR
LEVELS OF EFFORT. AND I THINK
THAT'S ANOTHER CHALLENGE THAT I
HAVE WITH THE BILL THE OTHER
THING I WANT TO BRING UP AND-
YOU KNOW AND I DO REALLY
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH ALL THE
COMMENTS MADE BY PACIFIC FROM
MY COLLEAGUES IN LOS ANGELES-
WE HAD SEVERAL WHO HAVE.
BROUGHT UP A NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT I WON'T REPEAT- BUT THERE
IS A WHOLE OTHER CHALLENGES TO
SEE WITH HISTORIC ZONES. MAKING
SURE THERE ARE- WITH THE WITH
THE STORE CHARACTER OF A MANY
OF OUR NEIGHBORS IS. EVAN
PROTECTED I KNOW THERE'S SOME
WHICH IN THE BILL RIGHT NOW TO
PRESERVE. AND PROTECT THOSE
HISTORIC ZONES THAT WERE
REGISTERED WITH THE STATE.
PRIOR TO TWENTY TEN. BUT THE
FACT THE MATTER IS THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE STARK SONS
IN THE STATE. WE'RE NOT
REGISTERED WITH THE STATE THE-
SERVER THERE CAN WITH A- CITIES.
BECAUSE THERE WAS ACTUALLY NO.
TO SIR WITH THE STATE HAVE TO
BE VERY EXCITED. I YEARS ON TO
REGISTER. SALINAS REASON. YEAH
AND I WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT
AS WELL BECAUSE- WE'VE A LOT OF
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WOULD BE
REAL IN IN. I THINK THAT A LOT
OF MEMBERS DON'T DON'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THE REALITY IN AND
WHERE THE BILL IS SO FOR THAT
REASON I AM NOT GOING UP ON THE
BILL TODAY. SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU A MAN PRESIDENT CHAN
I WASN'T PLANNING ON SPEAKING-
CHAIR WITH YOU VERY BRIEFLY I
COME FROM A COMMUNITY SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY THAT WAS BUILT ON
25% AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENT
BY THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WE
ENTERED OUR CITIES AND MINE
THIRTY YEARS AGO WE HAVE 525%
AFFORDABLE AFFORDABILITY TO LOW
VERY LOW AND MODERATE AND TODAY
NONE OF THOSE- RESIDENTS EXIST
LIKE THINK THE MEDIAN ALL HOME
PRICE IN JUST MY CDS EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ALL
AROUND ME AND IT GOES UP FROM
THERE AND HE AND SANTA MANY OF
FOR MILLION TO. LAGUNA BEACH IS
OVER TWO MILLION AND THOSE ARE
PLACES WHERE THERE WAS A
REQUIREMENT FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO THAT'S NUMBER ONE
I'M NOT SURE OVER THE LONG HAUL
WE'RE ABLE TO BECAUSE OF
PROPERTY RIGHTS AND SECOND
GENERATIONS TO HOLD IT THAT WAY
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE SHOULDN'T
TRY BUT THERE'S A COMMON
DOMINATOR AND EVERYTHING WE'VE
HEARD FROM OUR CITIES AND I'D
LIKE US TO PAY CLOSE ATTENTION
TO THAT BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
THE KEY THE KEY TO SOLVING THE
PROBLEM AND IT DOES NEED MORE
TIME AND- I'D LIKE TO READ IF I
MAY MADAM PRESIDENT IT COMES
FROM THE CITY OF CARLSBAD A
LARGE COASTAL CITY. THIS NOT
EXEMPTED THEIR POPULATION IS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN THOUSAND
BETTER BUT THEY ARE SAYING IN
THIS GOES TO THE HARD WORK OF
OUR OF. JERRY I THINK NOBLE
FINISH FOR. THE SAN FRANCISCO
WHOSE WORK SO HARD BUT THERE'S
STILL MORE TO DO. THEY SAY THE
CITY IS ENCOURAGED BY RECENT
AMENDMENTS THAT APPEAR TO
PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
AN ALTERNATIVE PLANNING
PROCESS. TO DEVELOP LOCAL
FLEXIBILITY PLAN TO MEET THE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES OF. SENATE
BILL FIFTY I'VE HEARD A NUMBER
OF MY- COLLEAGUES. THIS
AFTERNOON REFER TO THAT ALL
WILL THE CITIES HAVE.
DISCRETION WHAT THEY REALLY
DON'T BECAUSE THERE'S NO
CRITERIA THAT'S BEEN DEVELOPED
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WHAT WE'RE DOING WE'RE
DELEGATING THAT AUTHORITY TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING. AND
RESEARCH TO DEVELOP RULES
REGULATIONS OR GUIDELINES FOR
SUBMISSION OF A LOCAL
FLEXIBILITY PLAN. EVERYONE OF
US KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN BILLS
GO THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD WITH THE PROMISES THAT
ARE THERE THAT IS GOING TO BE
FLEXIBLE IS GOING TO ADDRESS
LOW INCOME FOLKS. AND THAT DOES
NOT HAPPEN BECAUSE IT DOES NOT
COME BACK TO US WE HAD A NUMBER
OF DEBATES WHEN I WAS FIRST ON
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
COMMITTEE THAT THE THING SHOULD
COME BACK TO LEAVE OUR FORMER
PUT HIM. OF RESPONSIBLY AND ON
FEW OF THOSE. CONTENTIOUS THAT.
ARE LOW NEIGHBORHOODS THE WOULD
COME OUT IT DID NOT. SO THIS
THE LACK OF TRUST IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL THAT THIS WILL
COME OUT. FOR HERE NOT AN
IMMENSE THAT GO A LONG WAY TO
TRY TO SOLVE WHAT I CONSIDER TO
BE. THE COMMON DENOMINATOR
WHERE YOU HAVE RESISTANCE
MARSEILLE. FIFTY HIGH EMAIL ARE
THOUGHT THE DAY. FROM THESE
COMMUNITIES ALL OVER THE STATE
A LOT FOR MY DISTRICT WITH MANY
UP A DOWN THIS. I HAVE OVER
FIFTY LETTERS HERE FROM CITIES
OBJECTING TO THIS ON THAT
SPECIFIC ISSUE. THAT'S WHAT THE
NEED WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE
THAT'S WHERE WE CAN ABDICATE
OUR RESPONSE WE NEED TO BE PART.
OF THE- MAKE FOR VERY VERY POOR.
STEP WE'RE TAKING TO CREATE A
FOR. IN THIS. SO I COULD NOT SO
TODAY I PLEDGE ISSUE AND THE
FACT THAT OUR COMMUNITY WAS
BECOMING ONLY ONE FOR A LEAD.
WE MADE A DIFFERENCE WHO WORKED
WITH OUR DEVELOPERS WE HAD A
LOT OF MEETINGS THAT WE CHANGE
SOME OF THE DEVELOPMENT
STANDARDS THEM AND WE WERE ABLE
TO BUILD MULTI FAMILY. IF YOU
DRIVE THE I FIVE THAT CROWN
VALLEY AND THE I. FIVE YOU'LL
SEE A NUMBER. OF AYE NEW
APARTMENTS THAT HAVE BUILT IN
BUILT ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
FREEWAY THERE TO ADDRESS THIS
BUT WE HAVE TO GIVE OUR CITIES.
THE ABILITY TO BE INVOLVED IN
THAT LOCAL FLEXIBILITY PLANET
WE CAN ONLY DO THAT THROUGH THE
REPRESENTATIVES THAT SIT ON
THIS FLOOR. AND I THINK THEN WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD VERY RAPIDLY
AND MEET THOSE DEADLINES THAT
WE ARE TRYING TO CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- IN OUR
STATE. THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
SENATE SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES I HAD I ALSO WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES-
JUST FOR THE VERY THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSION AS WELL AS OUR
SENATOR FROM SACKED FROM STORMS
ARE NOT FROM SACRAMENTO FROM
SAN FRANCISCO I REALLY
APPRECIATE- YOUR WORK YOU MET
WITH MANY OF MY CITIES AND I
JUST APPRECIATE THAT- THAT WORK
UP UNTIL NOW AND SO JUST A FEW
THINGSTHAT CAME IN JUST KIND
OF HOT OFF THE PRESSES THAT I
WANTED TO ENSURE THAT I WAS
ADDRESSING ON BEHALF OF A HALF
OF MY CITY. ARE HAVE THE
DISTRICT WHICH IS A CITY OF
LONG BEACH ACTUALLY PROP
PROVIDED REALLY GOOD SOLUTIONS
IN A PROPOSAL- WHICHHAD NOT
BEEN DISCUSSED BEFORE BUT JUST
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT
BECAUSE I MEN OF THE SAME
SENTIMENT WHETHER YOU ARE A YES
OR NO ON THIS I THINK WE'RE ALL
IN AGREEMENT THAT THIS HAS A
LOT MORE WORK TO DO. I'M STILL
NOT DONE. I HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS TONIGHT
I HAVE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH. MY CITIES AND ESPECIALLY
MANY OF YOUR CITIES WERE
SMALLER CITIES. THEY DON'T HAVE
THE CAPACITY IN FUNDING TO
PRODUCE HOUSING ELEMENTS EVEN
THE BASIC. EVEN BEFORE THIS
BECAME. A TO FRUITION. AND WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING THOSE SUPPORTS.
SECONDLY THE FLEXIBILITY PLAN
AS MENTIONED BEFORE YOU KNOW
IT'S A TWO OR A FIVE YEAR PLAN
WHICH ISN'T. NECESSARILY
EXPLICIT ON WHO IS A SENSE OF-
SENSITIVE COMMUNITY. BUT
PERHAPS A COULD BE IN. A THREE
YEAR PLAN. DOWN THE ROAD
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY CITIES
LIKE A CITY OF LONG BEACH OR
SOME OTHER CITIES THAT ARE
SPOTTY. THERE'S SOME PLACES
THAT ARE SENSITIVE THERE'S SOME
PLACES THAT ARE NOT. AND LASTLY
I JUST WANT TO SAY WE HAVE TO
FIGHT FOR YOU KNOW WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT INCLUSIONARY
ZONING COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AS WELL. FROM A CITY
THAT HAS BEEN TRYING TO PUSH
FOR INCLUSIONARY ZONING AND
DIDN'T HASN'T HAD IT DONE YET.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
INCLUSIONARY ZONING IS
EVERYWHERE- RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
FEW CITIES WHO ARE DOING IT AND
A LOT WHO ARE NOT. A LOT TO DO
NOT HAVE ANY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
REQUIREMENTS WHATSOEVER AS WE
KNOW- I CAME OFF OF A GENERAL
USE PLAN LAND USE PLAN AS WELL
AND IN THE CITY OF LONG BEACH-
AND ALSO WITH WITHIN THAT HAD A
SPECIFIC PLAN AHEAD ZERO.
REQUIREMENTS FOR AFFORDABLE. SO
WE NEED TO DO A LOT OF WORK
THERE AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU AGAIN AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING BUT I
WILL BE SUPPORT TODAY. IF THERE
ARE NO MORE IF THERE IS NO MORE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S
ALREADY SPOKEN CENTER WIENER
YOU. CAN FINISH. INCLUDE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT BECAUSE I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU. ARE
FOR THE DATE TODAY INCLUDING
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT SUPPORTIVE
OF THE BILL. I THINK THE LENGTH
AND THE THOUGHTFULNESS AND THE
END OF NATURE. OF THIS DEBATE.
BY SEARCHING FOR SO WHY I'M SO
PROUD. TO BE A MEMBER OF THIS
BODY- WE THIS IS A TEST- IT IS
A VERY THOUGHTFUL. ON BODY AND
PEOPLE WHO CLEARLY-
UNDERSTANDS- THE BILL THAT
WE'RE DEBATING AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. BUT I JUST BRINGING THIS
TO A VERYHIGH LEVE TO LOOK AT
THE BIG PICTURE. BY THE NUMBERS
COULD NOT BE MORE STARK IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE SHORT THREE
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION HOMES
IN CALIFORNIA. MILLIONS OF
HOMES THIS IS IN A SMALL
PROBLEM. THIS IS A MASSIVE
PROBLEM. WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOMES
PER CAPITA. OF HOW MANY HOUSING
UNITS THE STATE HAS PERSONS HOW
MANY PEOPLE LIVE IN NOT SAYING
YOU DO A RATIO HOMES FOR
CAPITAL. AND YOU RANK THE FIFTY
STATES. CALIFORNIA IS NUMBER
FORTY NINE. YOU T<c.cyan> IS THE</c>
ONLY ONE THAT'S- BELOW US AND
UTAH HAS LARGER HOUSEHOLD SIZE
IS THEY DON'T NEED AS MANY
HOUSING UNITS THAT WERE
ESSENTIALLY BOTTOM OF THE
BARREL. WHEN IT COMES TO SIMPLY
PROVIDING HOUSING FOR OUR
POPULATION. HOW MANY LOOK AT
HOUSING PRODUCTION TRENDS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN THE EARLY
SIXTIES WE WERE BUILDING
BETWEEN. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND UNITS OF HOUSING A
YEAR AS A STATE OF FIFTEEN
MILLION PEOPLE. TODAY WE ARE
STATE OF FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
AND WE'RE PRODUCING LESS THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR FEWER THAN
A HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS OF
HOUSING A YEAR. OUR POPULATION
OVER SIXTY YEARS ALMOST TRIPLED
OUR HOUSING PRODUCTION
COLLAPSED BY ABOUT TWO THIRDS
OR THREE QUARTERS ANYWAY YOU
SLICE THE NUMBERS. THERE IS NO
DOUBT THAT WE NEED A DRAMATIC
INCREASE. IN HOUSING OF ALL
TYPES AND YES THAT INCLUDES
SUBSIDIZE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND THIS SB FIFTY WILL PROVIDE
THE BASE ZONING AS A SENATOR
FROM SAN DIEGO MENTION SO THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND I AM
FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF EFFORTS
SUCH AS A SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE
TO DRAMATICALLY INCREASE OUR
PERMANENT FUNDING SOURCES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. YES WE NEED
A TO USE AND WE'RE DONE GOOD
WORK THERE BUT THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH AND WE NEED TO ZONE OUR
STATE PER AYE WE NEED HIS OWN
CALIFORNIA. TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO BUILD ENOUGH HOUSING AND
THAT'S WHAT SB FIFTY WILL DO
AND WILL DO IT IN A WAY. THAT
IT WON'T CREATE SPRAWL. THIS IS
ABOUT REAL PEOPLE AS I SAID AT
THE BEGINNING. IT'S NOT ABOUT
HIS NUMBERS AND STATISTICS.
THIS IS ABOUT CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE HURTING RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO REPRESENT
THEM. I'M A HUGE FAN OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- I. THE FORMER LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIAL I TALKED TO
MY- BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
MEMBERS. CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
ALL THE TIME AND I'M ENORMOUS
RESPECT FOR THEM. BUT I ALSO
KNOW THAT MY CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS. AND SPORTS OF
SUPERVISORS ARE NOT THE ONE WHO
WANTS TO ELECTED OFFICE. AND
SOMETIMES THEY DISAGREE WITH ME
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OPPOSES THIS BILL.
THAT'S OKAY BECAUSE I'M
SELECTED BY THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
ELECTED THEM. I'M MY OBLIGATION
IS TO THE MILLION PEOPLE. WHO
ARE THE RESIDENTS OF MY
DISTRICT AND SO YES OF COURSE
CITY COUNCILS MATTER. BUT
ULTIMATELY WE ARE HERE TO
REPRESENT THOSE MILLION PEOPLE.
WHO ARE SUFFERING RIGHT NOW
MANY OF THEM AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. I'M SICK.
KERRY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN NO ARCHULETA. ATKINS AYE
BATES NO WELL I FORGES NO
BRADFORD. COME BY ADAM HI I
CHIANG. DALLY FIVE DODD.
THEY'RE ALSO NO GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER NO GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HERTZBERG NO HILL NO WAY SO. I
TADO I JACKSON NO JONES NO
LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL NO
MONNING I MORE LOCK. MORRELL
NIELSEN AYE PAN I PORTANTINO NO
ROB I RUBIO NO SKINNER I STERN
NO NUMBER. WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE
WIENER AYE WILK NO. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
BRADFORD. CHIANG DODD. GROWTH
MORE LOCK. AROUND NUMBER.
SENATOR WIENER MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SIX. SENATOR UMBERG
ARE YOU READY. HE IS MAD PLEASE.
TO READ. SENATE BILL FOR FORTY
FOUR BY SENATOR UMBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. SENATE REMEMBER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SP FOUR FOUR FOUR
WHICH ALLOW THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA IRVINE SCHOOL LAW IN
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY SCHOOL LAW TO WORK
WITH THEIR RESPECTIVE COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURTS. DEVELOP
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE THAT
ASSIST SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS ACCORDING TO JUDICIAL
COUNCIL OVER FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS REPRESENT
THEMSELVES- IN AND WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS THIS BILL ALLOWS
THOSE INSTITUTIONS TO WORK
TOGETHER TO DEVELOP MECHANISMS
SO THAT FOR EXAMPLE A VICTIM OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHEN HE OR
SHE FILLS OUT. THE FORM-
REQUESTING RESTRAINING ORDER OR
A PROTECTIVE ORDER THAT SHOULD
AN ELEMENT NOT BE PRESENT THAT
THAT THAT WOULD NOTIFY THE
APPLICANT THAT AN ELEMENT IS
NOT PRESENT RATHER THAN HAVING
THEM COME BACK ON ANOTHER DAY.
TO HAVE THE BENCH OFFICER
ULTIMATELY DETERMINE AND IT
WOULD BE A BENCH OFFICER
ULTIMATELY DETERMINES THE
PROPRIETY OF WILL PERFORM IS
SUBMITTED. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION- DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. I WELL I FOR
JUST AYE BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO
AYE CHIANG. I DOLLY I DOT I
DRAW SO I TELL JOHNNY. GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG
I HILL BY PLACER. I TADO I
JACKSON AYE JONES. I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. FIVE
MONNING I MORE LOCK AYE MORRELL.
I NIELSEN AYE PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN I AM BURKE I
LIKE CASTING. I WIENER AYE WILK
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GALGIANI. I GROWTH.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. SENATOR ALAN
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FORTY
FIVE BY SENATOR ALLEN AN ACT
RELATING TO A WILDFIRE
PREVENTION SAFE DRINKING WATER
DROUGHT CORPORATION AND FLOOD
PROTECTION PROGRAM BY PROVIDING
THE FUNDS NECESSARY THEREFORE
THROUGH AN ELECTION FOR THE
ISSUANCE AND SAFE SALE OF BONDS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
FOR THE HANDLING AND
DISPOSITION OF THOSE FUNDS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR ALAN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS IF PASSED BY
OUR VOTERS SB FORTY FIVE WOULD
FIND ON THE GROUND PROJECTS
DESIGNED TO HELP PREPARE FOR
SEVERE WILDFIRES CATASTROPHIC
FLOODS MUD SLIDES PROLONGED
DROUGHTS EXTREME HEAT THE LEVEL
RISE ANOTHER EXTREME WEATHER
EVENTS WE'RE ALREADY SEEING AS
A RESULT OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
ACCORD OUR STATE'S FOURTH
CLIMATE ASSESSMENT THE COST OF
CLIMATE CHANGE FOR CALIFORNIA
ALONE AS LIKELY TO BE OVER A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY WITHIN A COUPLE
DECADES HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY I JUST WANNA REPEAT
THE SIZE. OF THE CHALLENGE. I
THIS BILL SETS A COURSE TO
REDUCE THE IMPACT OF RISING
GLOBAL TEMPERATURES BY
INVESTING IN MEASURES IN EVERY
PART OF THE STATE TO PROTECT.
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES IN
BILATERAL RESURCES FROM THESE
RISKS. THE BILL THAT A CASE
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING TO PROJECTS
THAT REDUCE FIRE HE THE FIRE
RISK NEAR COMMUNITIES ENSURE
OUR FORESTS. ARE HEALTHY ENOUGH
TO WITHSTAND MORE INTENSE
WILDFIRES ACCORDING TO FEMA OUR
FRIENDS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
EVERY DOLLAR INVESTED. IN
ACTIVITIES TO PREVENT FIRES OR
MITIGATE SEVERITY SAVE SIX
DOLLARS IN RESPONSE COSTS.
WARMING TEMPERATURES WILL ALSO
INCREASE THE FREQUENCY OF
FLIGHTS GET OUR STATE IS
CURRENTLY INVESTING LESS THAN
HALF OF WHAT IS NEEDED TO
PROPERLY ADDRESS THIS GROWING
RISK WHICH IS ESTIMATED NOW TO
BE MORE. THAN THIRTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS AND GROWING. SB
FORTY FIVE DEDICATES FUNDING A
PROJECT THAT WILL REDUCE THIS
RISK BY SLOWING RUNOFF.
IMPROVING GROUND WATER
INFILTRATION AND PROTECTING
COASTAL COMMUNITIES. FROM SEA
LEVEL RISE. IN OUR URBAN
COMMUNITIES EXTREME HEAT EVENTS
CAN BE DEADLY ESPECIALLY FOR
OLDER ADULTS YOUNG CHILDREN.
PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC ILLNESS
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES. AND
AS A RESULT THE BILL DIRECTS
FUNDING TO HELP LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ADAPT TO RISING
TEMPERATURES BY REDUCE THE HEAT
ISLAND EFFECT THROUGH. GREETING
PROJECTS IN CAPTURING STORM
WATER TO HELP STABILIZE
DRINKING WATER SUPPLIES. THE
MEASURE ALSO PROPOSES TO FIND
PROJECTS TO RESTORE AND
PROTECT. IMPACTED COASTAL
RESOURCES IN FOR. FISH AND
WILDLIFE POPULATIONS AS WELL AS
IMPROVE THE RESILIENCY OF THE
STATE'S WATER SUPPLIES.
AGRICULTURAL LANDS. IT'S OUR
STRONG SENSE THAT WE MUST TAKE
CARE AGGRESSIVE PROACTIVE STEPS
TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE IMPACTS.
THAT WE KNOW ARE COMING WE KNOW
ALREADY UPON US. THE BILL AS
THE FORTY FIVE IS A FISCALLY
PRUDENT STEP IN THAT DIRECTION
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ADAM
PRO TEM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I- RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FORTY FIVE WHEN WE FIRST
CONVENE THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE WERE STRUGGLING
WITH THE IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF
THE CAMPFIRE COMMUNITIES ACROSS
OUR STATE WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF RECOVERY AND REBUILDING
AFTER CLIMATE RELATED DISASTERS
DEVASTATING FIRES MUDSLIDES
FLOODING AND MORE I SAID THEN
THAT RESILIENCE MUST BE A
PRIORITY FOR THE SENATE AND IN
MANY WAYS IT'S BEEN OUR
PRINCIPAL FOCUS. FIGHTING
WILDFIRES ENSURING THE
RELIABILITY OF OUR ENERGY
SYSTEM ENSURING ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR EVERY
CALIFORNIA DESERVE THE VERY
REAL CHALLENGES OF CHANGING
CLIMATE HERE AND NOW THIS BOND
WILL GIVE US THE RESOURCES WE
NEED TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
BY ADDRESSING SEA LEVEL RISE
PREVENTING WILDFIRES PREPARING
FOR FUTURE DROUGHTS AND FLOODS
AND PROTECTING OUR PRECIOUS
WATER RESOURCES. IN ADDITION TO
STATE WHAT FUNDING THAT WILL
BENEFIT INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
IN EVERY PART OF THE STATE
THERE'S ALSO LOCALIZED FUNDING
TO EMPOWER FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES TO SECURE OUR MOST
VITAL RESOURCES AND COLLEAGUES
THE COMMUNITIES NEED THESE
RESOURCES. THIS IS ONE AREA
WHERE MANY OF THEM WOULD LIKE
OUR SUPPORT SB FORTY FIVE
REQUIRES THAT AT LEAST 35% OF
ITS FUNDS BE SPENT TO BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS THIS IS
THE FIRST AND BY FAR THE
LARGEST SINGLE STATE OF NEW
INVESTMENT FOR CLIMB RE. A.
SENATOR MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- TALK ABOUT
EXISTENTIAL THREATS THE ONE
THAT WORRIES ME THE MOST IS
FISCAL DISTRESS- SO I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TENURE PLANNER TWENTY
YEAR PLANNER THIRTY YEAR
STRATEGIC FINANCIAL PLAN THIS
LEGISLATURE'S READING FROM-
BUT- I'M I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED
JUST WATCHING THE TRENDS THIS
YEAR WE HAD A TWENTY ONE
MILLION DOLLAR QUOTE UNQUOTE
SURPLUS. NEXT YEAR IS SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR. QUOTE UNQUOTE
SURPLUS WITH THAT TREND WE WILL
HAVE AN A DEFICIT OF FOURTEEN
BILLION AND THEN THE FOLLOWING
YEAR SO WHERE WILL THE MONEY
COME FROM TO PAY FOR THE BONDS
OUR POPULATION TRENDS ARE
FLATTENING. TAXES ARE HIGHER
THAN ALMOST EVERY OTHER STATE
IN ALMOST EVERY CATEGORY A SO
WE SURE THEY CAN'T RAISE TAXES
MORE WE HAVE ANOTHER BOND
MEASURE ON THE MARCH BALLOT AS
WELL. SO WHAT WILL THIS
LEGISLATURE CUT. TO PAY
BONDHOLDERS. ENDING YEARS OF
PLENTY WHY DOES THIS CAPITAL
NOT PAY CASH INSTEAD WERE
FORCING OUR TAXPAYERS TO PAY
DOUBLE WITH PRINCIPAL AND
INTEREST. CALIFORNIA HAS THE
LARGEST. AS THE SECOND LARGEST
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT IN THE
NATION IT'S TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS JUST READ YOUR
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORT. WE USUALLY END UP IN
LAST PLACE FIFTY OF PLACEMENT.
THIS YEAR. ENDED JUNE THIRTY.
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTEEN THE STATE
OF NEW JERSEY PUMP THIS OUT OF
PLACE THEY ARE AT TWO HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
COLLEAGUES ARE DEBT RATIOS ARE
THE THIRD WORST AMONG THE TEN
LARGEST STATES IN CALIFORNIA IS
EDGED OUT BY NEW YORK IN
ILLINOIS AND SPEAKING OF
ILLINOIS IT'S UNRESTRICTED NET
DEFICIT IS TWO HUNDRED NINE
POINT NINE BILLION WE'RE NOT IN
GOOD COMPANY. SO YOU'RE REVENUE
ASSUMPTIONS ARE VERY OPTIMISTIC
YES THE STOCK MARKET HAS RISEN
50% SINCE DONALD TRUMP WAS
ELECTED PRESIDENT BUT DO YOU
REALLY EXPECT THAT TREND TO
CONTINUE FOR THE REST OF OUR
LIFETIMES I AM NOT HERE TO
ARGUE THE MERITS OF THE USE OF
THE BOND PROCEEDS I AM HERE TO
ASK YOU QUIT IN COVERING
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN. PAY OFF YOUR
CREDIT CARDS FIRST ADDRESS THE
DEFINED BENEFIT AND OTHER POST
EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS UNFUNDED
ACTUARIAL ACCRUED LIABILITIES
SHOW SOME FISCAL PRUDENCE THEN
TRY YOUR BEST TO PAY CASH AND
THEN WERE ALL CUT UP THEN YOU
IS TO BONDS THAT WE COULD HAVE
A VERY SHOULD PERIOD OF TIME.
YOU KNOW THIS THEY CAN'T EVEN
MY ITS- AND WE HAD A RACE TO.
FOR THAT WE GOT TO START BEING
A LITTLE MORE. FISCALLY A
WEARABLE WE'RE DO CALL BEFORE
WE FIND OURSELVES HAVING A
BUDGET THAT IS SO SQUEEZED.
ACCORDINGLY I REQUEST THE NO
VOTE ON SB FORTY FIVE. SENATOR
GLAZER. THANK YOU ARE MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. WHEN WE MAKE
CHOICES ABOUT MEASURES LIKE
THIS IT'S ABOUT SETTING
PRIORITIES AND I THINK IF YOU
WERE AT TO ASK THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THIS WOULD
PROPOSE TO DO THAT DO YOU THINK
THAT WILDLIFE PREVENTION IS A
HIGH PRIORITY FOR OUR STATE
BUDGET I THINK THE ANSWER WOULD
BE YES AND YOU ASK THEM ABOUT
DROUGHT PREPARATION WOULD THAT
BE A HIGH PRIORITY BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO SET PRIORITIES I THINK
THE ANSWER WOULD BE YES AND SO
AS YOU LOOK THROUGH THE
PURPOSES OF THIS MEASURE. ON
THE IT YOU KNOW THE LEGITIMATE
QUESTION THAT'S RAISED BY THE
SENATOR ROM ORANGE COUNTY I
THINK THAT THIS IS A MATTER OF
SETTING PRIORITIES READY GIVE
THE VOTERS THAT CHANCE AND I
THINK THAT THEIR ANSWER WILL
BE. YES I WANT TO GIVE PRAISE
TO THE AUTHORS. THEY SEEM TO BE
OFF LOS. BACK IN THE SAME ABOUT
THAT. BUT I WOULD NOTE THAT IN
THE IN THE BILL IT DOES SET
ASIDE ALLOCATIONS I AM PRIORITY
AREAS FROM ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE DONE GREAT WORK IN OUR
STATE HAVE PROVEN TRACK RECORDS
CERTAINLY THE CONSERVANCY'S.
BUT ALL I WOULD ASK- TO THE
AUTHORS IS THIS BILL HOPEFULLY
MOVES FORWARD TODAY. IS THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE BALANCE I
GEOGRAPHIC BALANCE IN IN THE
WORK THAT WE DO THE IMPORTANT
WORK THAT WE DO IN THIS BILL
AND I HOPE THAT THAT WILL BE A
PART OF THE WORK THAT THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO DO- WHEN THIS WHERE
THE MEASURE GOES FORWARD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND ENERGY AND I
VOTE. SENATOR DRAWS OF. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FIVE
CLIMATE CHANGE IS INDEED
DRAMATICALLY IMPACT IN OUR
ECONOMY AND ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES IN PARTICULAR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WILL BE
MOST AFFECTED BY CLIMATE CHANGE
AND ECONOMIC SHIFTS THAT IS WHY
I WANT TO URGE THE AUTHOR TO
GIVE GREATER PRIORITY TO
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IN THESE
PROJECTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES I
BELIEVE WE NEED TO BE MORE
INTENTIONAL AND EXPLICIT. IN
OUR JOB COMMITMENTS IN OUR JOB
CREATION AND CREATING PATHWAYS
TO GOOD NEW CAREERS SB FORTY
FIVE NOW HAS IS THAT A FIVE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS MORE
OR LESS- AND SIXTY MILLION
ALLOCATED FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT I WOULD URGE TO
INCREASE THAT ALLOCATION I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT HIGH QUALITY
JOBS WILL BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. SENATOR
BILL. MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
SUPPORT THIS SO LEGISLATION AND
THE BONDS AND URGED VOTERS TO
APPROVE IT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS- WITHHELD FUNDS
NOT SPENT FUNDS ON MANY OF
THESE THINGS FOR MANY YEARS
THIS IN MY OPINION IS BILLS
PASSED DO. AND IN ORDER TO
FINANCE THEM APPROPRIATELY
THESE BONDS ARE IN ORDER I LIKE
TO POINT OUT TO THE BOND RATING
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS- ALL ONE HAS
TO DO IS TO GO TO THE PUBLISHED
CREDIT RATINGS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO SEE. HOW THEY
VIEW BONDS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE CREDIT RATING IS
IN A PRETTY GOOD SHAPE AND WILL
GET MUCH BETTER AS WE GO ALONG.
WHAT DOESN'T HELP OUR CREDIT
RATING IF WE LET THINGS FALL
APART. AND IT WITHOUT THESE
BONDS ARE WITH I ARE THAT MANY
MANY OF OUR ON NAY UNMET.
PRIORITIES WILL CONTINUE TO
DETERIORATE AND THUS BECOME
MORE EXPENSIVE AND MORE COSTLY.
PAY AS YOU GO IS NOT A GOOD
OPTION LET'S FIND THE PROJECTS
NOW. USING BONDS THAT WE CAN
GET OUT OF A REVERIE
RESPECTABLE INTEREST RATE AND
COST. AND LET'S PROCEED AHEAD
WITH THOSE PROJECTS THAT ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED TODAY NOT IN
THE FUTURE BUT TODAY. AND HAVE
BEEN LONG PAST DUE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARJUNA VOTE
ON THIS MOTION. SENATOR STERN.
AT THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
JUST SAY APPRECIATE THE SAN
FROM COST CONTRA COSTA SANTOS
AND FOR ON. CHOICES PRIORITIES
IN FISCAL RISK- WE CAN'T AFFORD
NOT TO PASS A MAJOR BOND THIS
YEAR ON THIS FRONT. THE CREDIT
RISK TO THE STATE OF NOT ACTING
IN A SIGNIFICANT WAY TO HARDEN
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE WILL LEAVE
US EXPOSED TO BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF SURPRISES
ESSENTIALLY. OVER THE NEXT
DECADES YOU DON'T KNOW WHEN THE
NEXT. ATMOSPHERIC RIVER IS
COMING YOU DON'T KNOW WHEN THE
NEXT FIRES GOING TO HIT YOUR
COMMUNITY LAST YEAR WE GOT HIT.
YOU COULD CALL IT OUT OF THE
BLUE BY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO GO
DEAL WITH ALL THE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES. IF WE DON'T GET
AHEAD OF THESE DISASTERS WE'RE
GOING TO PAY FOR IT ON THE BACK
AND- SO IT MAY SOUND TO YOU
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS SOUNDS
LIKE A LOT OF MONEY OR FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IS A LOT OF
MONEY. WHEN YOU LOOK AT JUST
ONE INCIDENT. USGS A VERY
CONSERVATIVE SOBRE FEDERAL
GEOLOGIC SURVEY AGENCY MODEL
SOMETHING CALLED THE ARK STORM.
AND IT'S NOT A R. C. AS ARC
STORM IT'S PARK IS IN NOVA NO
WAS ARC STORM. IS IT IS SUPER
FLOOD IS QUITE LIKELY OVER THE
NEXT TWENTY YEARS. THAT
WOULDN'T JUST COMPLETELY SINK.
SACRAMENTO IN THE DELTA REGIONS
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUT ALSO
LOS ANGELES. ORANGE COUNTY DOWN
IN THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY A SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR ALL OUT CATASTROPHE. IF
WE DON'T START DOING THINGS
LIKE HARDEN ARE LEVEES PREPARE
FOR THESE FLOODS IT'S NOT JUST
FIRES FOLKS SO I APPRECIATE THE
GOOD WORK DONE BY EVERYBODY
HERE TODAY- BUT THIS WORK
PRODUCTS GOING AFTER OF ALL OF
AS WE GO FORWARD. WE KNOW THE
GOVERNOR HAS SOME IMPORTANT
PRIORITIES WE LOOK FORTY
HEARING WITH THIS THE
ASSEMBLIES PRIORITIES- AND THE
ONE THING I WOULD ENCOURAGE US
ALL IS- DON'T UNDER DO IT. THE
VOTERS ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
INCREMENTALISM HERE. WE NEED A
BOLD CHANGE SO IF IT'S A MATTER
OF. WHETHER WE'RE SPENDING TOO
LITTLE I THINK WE'VE ASKED
OURSELVES THE WRONG QUESTION
IT'S WHETHER WE'RE SPENDING
ENOUGH. AND WE'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA MAKE PEOPLE SAFE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES WE NEED TO GET
SERIOUS ABOUT SCALE HERE. SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE- SENATOR ROTH. I
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT- IN
A WILDFIRE PREVENTION SAFE
DRINKING WATER DROP. PREVENTION
PREPARATION FLOOD PROTECTION
ROLE OBVIOUSLY IMPORTANT VERY
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES TO- ALL
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS IN THE
STATE INTO THE STATE AS A WHOLE
I PLAN ON SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
MEASURE APPEARS TO INCLUDE SOME
OPERATIONAL ITEMS FOR
MANAGEMENT AND FOR PLANNING. IN
ADDITION TO CAPITAL PROJECTS
AND FRANKLY I PREFER TO BORROW
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE IN THE BOND MEASURE BORROW
FOR CAPITAL PROJECTS AND NOT
BORROW FOR OPERATIONAL ISSUES
SO. AS THIS MATTER MOVES
FORWARD I WOULD ASK THAT THE
AUTHOR TAKE A LOOK AT THAT- AND
THE PROPRIETY OF ACTUALLY
FLOATING A BOND. TO BORROW
MONEY FOR OPERATIONAL ISSUES I
THINK WE CAN PROBABLY. CUT THIS
DOWN TO CAPITAL PROJECTS AND DO
MUCH BETTER IN THAT REGARD SO
URGENT AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. CENTER GALGIANI. I'M
I'M GOING TO BE WITH HOLDING MY
VOTE TODAY I APPRECIATE ALL OF
THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR BUT I
WAS HERE AS A STAFF MEMBER IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED PROPOSITION
ONE E. WHICH WAS FOR FLOOD
PROTECTION. AND IN THAT BOND
MEASURE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CENTRAL VALLEY
FLOOD PROTECTION. WE HAVE THE
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED MILES OR SO
OF LEVEES THAT ARE IN BOTH
SACRAMENTO AND SALLY CAN
COUNTIES AND SALAS CAN COUNTY
TO THIS DAY IS STILL TRYING TO
GET MONIES FROM PROPOSITION ONE
E. THE MONEY IN THE BOND WAS TO
REFER TO THE GENERAL FUND IF IT
WASN'T SPENT. BY I BELIEVE TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN AND WHILE
I WAS TRYING TO DO LEGISLATION
TOOK SAID IN THAT TIME PERIOD
SO THAT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
COULD. USE THOSE FUNDS LEVY.
AND STRENGTHENING THAT MONEY
INSTEAD MUCH OF IT IF NOT MOST
OF WHAT WAS HAVE WAS DIVERT
GENERAL FUND BE I CAST MY VOTE
ON THEIR I WANT A B. X. CLEAR
ABOUT EGGS. WHERE THE MONEY IS
GOING. HOW MUCH IS GOING TO THE
PROTECTION THIS OF. BECAUSE
ONLY TO VOTER AT THAT WHAT IT'S
FOR. THAT'S IT SHOULD BE FOR I
REMIND THAT AS EARLY AS THE
BEGAN OF THE WEEK I HAVE AN
EMAIL FROM MY- WHO IS TO GET
MONEY THAT WAS OF HAD FROM ONE
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX THANK YOU.
IS FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THIRTY AND PRESENTLY AND GERMS
OF THE CENTER I WORK VERY HARD
ON THAT PARTICULAR. TO ENSURE
CERTAIN THINGS WERE IN IT
INCLUDING WHAT MY FRIENDLY
SENATOR FROM THE VALLEY JUST
SPOKEN TO THE OR NOT READ THAT
EVERY I UNDER. IT'S NAY EACH.
BUT SOME OF WHAT WE A COP IN
LED TO. IS FACT BEING IGNORE.
NOW SOME FIVE YEARS LATER
THINGS THAT WERE TO BE DONE.
THERE'S AT THE LEAST IN
AGENCIES O STATE GOVERNMENT A
DRAGON OF HEELS. AND I CONSIDER
THAT UNDER THE PRESSURE FROM
VARIOUS AND SUNDRY SPECIAL
INTERESTS. WE CANNOT KEEP
PASSING BOND MEASURES. JUST AS
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT IF
YOU DO NOT SHOW YOUR LOCAL
CITIZENS THAT YOU DID WHAT YOU
SAID YOU WERE GOING TO DO
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SUPPORT
THESE THINGS. AND I'M- WARY OF
DOING THE HARD WAY THAT WAS.
THOUSANDS OF OUR THAT YOU.
NEGOTIATING A THAT VERY MAJOR
AND VERY IMPORTANT BOND. AND
HERE THAT YOU CAN WATCH YEARS
PASS. AND NOTHING HAPPENS.
EXCEPT PREVARICATION AND THE
LADY AND RESISTANCE. I'M NOT
PREPARED TO VOTE NO BUT I'M
CERTAINLY NOT PREPARED TO
SUPPORT THIS TODAY AND I DO
WANNA FLAG THE ISSUE WHEN WE
VOTE FOR THINGS WE HAVE A RIGHT
AN EXPECTATION AS MOST
IMPORTANTLY DO OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN. AND
GOVERNMENT THAT DOES NOT KEEP
ITS WORD. IS NOT A TRUSTED
GOVERNMENT. FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SING ON SENATOR
ALLEN YOU MAY CLOSE. MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION
AND I DO WANT TO THINK- MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SAN JOSE SAN
MATTEO SAN DIEGO FRESNO
SYNDROME- SAN FRANCISCO IN
ADDITION TO THE FOLKS FROM A
LOS ANGELES FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN HELPING TO AUTHORED THIS
BILL AND HELP US AS WE PULL IT
ALL TOGETHER- CERTAINLY WANT TO
SPEND SOME TIME I'VE YOU KNOW
NUMBER OF THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED- WE'RE JUST
REYES TO ME FOR THE FIRST TIME
TODAY AND- WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED MY OFFICE IS VERY.
SAID IN. ALL THE OFFICES IN
HEARING CONCERNS IN A SURE WE
GET THEM BECAUSE IT IS A
CONCERN SPECIAL IN PREVIOUS BY
MEASURES I GET THAT LET'S GET
THAT ADDRESS SO. TO ADD AN OPEN
CALL TO WILL THOSE FOLKS TO
RAISE TODAY TUNE TO THE OFFICE
AND ENSURE THAT WE CAN GET THIS
TO A PLACE WHERE ONE. GOOD
ABOUT IT WITH THAT I THINK THE
CASE IS. CLIMATE TO ME THIS IS.
VERY BEST. LONG TERM IN. I WILL
ALSO SAY TO ADDRESS THE- THAT
RAISED BY MY- COLLEAGUE FROM
RIVERS. THAT THE BOND ALL BY MY
DOES ALLOW PLANNING A TECHNICAL
SO. BUT NOT OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE OF ANY PROJECTS
AYE. I ACTUALLY AGREE WITH YOU
THAT A BOND IS THE
INAPPROPRIATE PLACE TO INVEST
IN. IN IN IN ONGOING COSTS BUT-
I SAW THAT SO I HOPE THAT THAT
THAT- IS YOURCONCERN WE CAN GO
BACK AND LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE
TO MAKE SURE THAT. IT'S AS AS
AS LOCKS LOCKS AS AS AS YOU
FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH BUT- WITH
THAT COLLEAGUES. LET'S LET'S.
LET'S LET'S MOVE FOR WITH THIS
AND LET'S WORK TOGETHER TO GET-
ALL WHATEVER CONCERNS ADDRESS
BUT NOW I THINK WE'RE VERY
CLOSE TO. TO A GOOD.
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE THAT
ADDRESSES THE ENORMOUS
LIABILITIES THAT FACE THE
STATE. MOVING FORWARD AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY THE
ROLE PLEASE. ALLEN I PARTULA I
ATKINS AYE BATES. WELL I FOR
JUST. BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO
AYE CHIANG. DALLY NO DODD. I
DORADO I COUNTY. GLAZER
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG HI
HILL AYE HUESO I TADO. I
JACKSON HI JOE. NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I MONNING
FIVE MORE LOOK NO MORALE. NO
NIELSEN. PAN I PORTANTINO I
ROTH AYE RUBIO I SKINNER. FIVE
STERN I AM BURKE I LIKE HOW SKI
FIVE WIENER. I WILK HI. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BASS
FOR JUST. CHIANG NO GALGIANI
GLAZER I GROWTH. NIELSEN. BATES
NOW. ICE TWENTY NINE A ICE
TWENTY NINE NO SIX ON THE
URGENCY IS FIVE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS SIX ON THE MEASURE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER NINE SENATOR STERN.
ARE YOU READY IT LOOKS LIKE HE
IS PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
FIVE NINETY SIX BY SENATOR
STERN AN ACT RELATING TO IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES BOARD
HERE SIR- THANK YOU MEMBERS-
THE RISE SB FIVE NOW SIX. WE
WENT THROUGH. COUNTLESS PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS THIS
FALL. BECOME A UNACCEPTABLE NEW
NORMAL IN OUR FIRE RAVAGED
AREAS OF THE STATE BUT WE FOUND
THAT AYE HSS WORKERS AND
CLIENTS WERE REALLY TIP OF THE
SPEAR HERE PEOPLE AT THERE'S
POWER SHUT OFF LITERALLY COULD
NOT. KEEP THEIR RESPIRATORS ON
KEEP THEIR MEDICINE
REFRIGERATED- UTILITIES ARE
PROGRAM CALLED MEDICAL BASELINE
RATES WITHIN WHICH AT LEAST
ALLOWS THE UTILITIES- TO
IDENTIFY HOMES THAT MAY NEED
BACK UP POWER IN SUPPORT BUT
RIGHT NOW A LOT OF THE AVERAGE
ASSESS COMMUNITIES NOT AWARE
THIS SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
BOTH THE WORKERS WHO MAKE I
JUST AS WORK DEPARTMENT AND THE
CLIENTS THEMSELVES TO HOPEFULLY
AT LEAST LET THEM KNOW ABOUT
THIS UTILITY PROGRAM WE HOPE
THE UTILITY STEP IN AND- MARKET
THESE PROGRAMS THE SAME IN THIS
IS NOT A TOTAL SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM BUT HOPEFULLY IT. MOVES
THE BALL POURED FOR THOSE
STRUGGLING WITH DISABILITIES
THOSE TRULY AT RISK MEDICALLY-
AND THOSE ACROSS CITY
CALIFORNIA'S RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I WILL. ANY DISCUSSION MADE.
SEEING NONE WITH A WE USE ARE
IF YES A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON.
SEEING NO OBJECTION I IS THERE
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO ITEM. TEN
SENATOR CHIANG IS A- PLEASE. NO
ONE SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY THREE
BY SOME CHIANG AND I RELATING
TO HEARARTS CENTER CHANGE THE
FOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
MEMBERS SIX FIFTY THREE EXPAND
ACCESS PREVENT DENTAL CARE BY
ALLOW HIGH CHEN OF THEIR CARRY
MORE PI HEALTH SAID AND IN
LIMITED CASES MEDICAL. THIS
BILL AS AMENDED REFER DISCUSS
WITH THE SO AND THE DENTAL
GENESIS SO SB SIX FIFTY THREE
SUPPORT BY BOTH GOOD AS WELL
CHILDREN THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE MEMBERS
THIS ITEM IS ALSO- WITHOUT
OBJECTION ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTION EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
SENATOR ALAN ARE YOU PREPARED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR ALLEN AND ACTUALLY
INTO STATE HIGHWAYS. MADAM
PRESIDENT THAT SIR SB SEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN MAKES OF A LITTLE
CHANGE TO THE STATE HIGHWAY
RELINQUISHMENT. PROCESS AND TO
MAKE IT A BIT EASIER FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WHO DESIRE TO
MANAGE AND MAKE CHANGES TO A
ROAD THAT NO LONGER SERVE THE
PURPOSE OF A TYPICAL HIGHWAY
THE BILL PROPOSES AN
ALTERNATIVE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS PERMITTING THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. TO RELINQUISH
PORTIONS OF THE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM TO A CITY OR COUNTY
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE ACTION. NO
MY INTENTION HERE IS NOT TO.
ANY OBJECT THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY SYSTEM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND SHOULD THE BOOK
THE BILL BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY. I
AM SO THE COMMITTED TO WORKING
I CONTINUE TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS WHO WANT GREATER
PARAMETERS AROUND THE SCOPE OF
SECTIONS OF HIGHWAYS. THAT
COULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
RELINQUISHMENT UNDER. THE
PARAMETERS OF THE BILL. I'M FOR
EXAMPLE I I'VE YOU KNOW WE'RE
BEEN WORK ONE OF ONE ARE
CALLING TO ON ON A ON AN ISSUE
ASSOCIATED WITH HER DISTRICT
BUT FOR THOSE APPROPRIATE
INSTANCES WHERE IT'S NOT
PRACTICABLE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO WORK THROUGH.
OUR STATE BUREAUCRACY TO MANAGE
OR MAKE IMPORTANT CHANGES A
LOCAL ROAD WHERE THEY ACTUALLY
MAKE THE DECISION THAT THEY
WANT TO TAKE CONTROL THE LOCAL
ROAD IN THE STATE. MAKES A
DECISION THAT THAT'S AN
APPROPRIATE THING TO HAPPEN-
THE BILL MAKES YOU DISHES BUT
IMPORT IMPROVEMENTS THE CURRENT
LAW. AND ALLOWS FOR THAT
PROCESS TO HAPPEN THIS
ULTIMATELY IS A WITH IT IS IT
IS IT IS A MECHANISM FOR OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO. ACHIEVE
IN A MORE EXPEDITED INJUDICIOUS
MANNER- SOMETHING THAT MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES OF STRUGGLE
WITH- WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
INTERPLAY BETWEEN. STATE
HIGHWAYS AND- AND THEIR THEIR
OWN LOCAL ROAD TRANSPORTATION
NEEDS AND SO. I WITHOUT EXPECT
FASTER NAY VOTE. IS ANY
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE THIS CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA I ATKINS
AYE BATES. WELL I FOR JUST.
FIVE HI COVER ADAM I CHIANG. I
DOLLY FIVE DOT. I ALSO I GOT YA
FIVE GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
HERTZ I HILL I HUESO. I TADA I
JACKSON FIVE JONES. I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I MONEY I
MORE LOCK MOREAU. I NIELSEN I
CAN. FIVE FOUR TO. BY ROB FIVE
REVIEW. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES GROWTH. MORE
LOCK. HI. THE MEASURE PASSES
ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT. SENATOR
WILK THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF THE CHIEF
ASSIGNMENT FOR RE APPOINTMENT
TO THE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
BOARD OF TRUSTEES MISS I MISS
PRESIDENT OF THE ATTIC CONDI
FOUNDATION HAS SERVED ON THE
BOARD SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON JANUARY
FIFTEENTH WITH THE UNANIMOUS
VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SAYING
NINE ZERO PLEASE. ALLEN AYE AYE
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BELL FIVE FOR JUST AYE
BRADFORD I HAVE A FIVE CHIANG.
DOLLY HI DODD. FIVE ASSUME BY A
JOHNNY I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE
HUESO AYE TADO. I JACKSON FIVE
JONES. FIVE LEYVA I MISS
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL I MONEY I
MORE LOCK AYE MORALE. NIELSEN
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH
FIVE RUBIO. I SKINNER. FIVE
STERN AYE NUMBER. I WHITE HOUSE
SKI FIVE WIENER AYE WILK FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CHIANG HI FIVE GROWTH BROWN.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO TAKE A
SMALL PAUSE AND ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE DON'T LEAVE THE FLOOR WE
HAVE A COUPLE MORE- TO GO BACK
TO A COUPLE BILLS ON CALL.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO GO BACK
TO THE ITEMS THAT ARE ON CALL.
WE'LL START OFF WITH ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT. SENATOR RIGHT
KASKI HOUSE KEYS SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA.
BATES FOR JUST NO AB FERN.
CABALLERO CHIANG. GLAZER.
GROWTH HELLO I MCGUIRE. PAN
PORTANTINO. RUBIO NUMBER. WILK.
TADO I'D TO KNOW WHO KNOWS.
WILL WELCOME NOW. I SEVENTEEN
KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE FAILS.
CENTER AYE KOWSKI MOVED FOR
RECONSIDERATION. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION RECONSIDERATION.
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED. ICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZEROS FOR
RECONSIDERATION MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB FIFTY I
CENTER WIENER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ARCHER ARCHER LETTER.
BRADFORD CHIANG. DODD GROWTH.
MORE LOCK. FIVE MORALE. NUMBER.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA BRADFORD. CHIANG DODD.
GROWTH MORALE. I'M BURKE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA BRADFORD. CHIANG DODD
NO GROSS MORALE. I'M BURKE. ICE
EIGHTEEN KNOWS FIFTEEN THE
MEASURE FAILS WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED. ICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
IS NO OTHER BUSINESS CENTER
ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TONE AND TENOR TODAY THANK YOU
FOR THE HARD WORK. WE STILL
HAVE ANOTHER DAY TO GO I WILL
SEE YOU TOMORROW THURSDAY
MORNING JANUARY THIRTIETH AT
NINE AM MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU. THE SENATE OUR IS
ADJOURNED WE WILL RECONVENE
TOMORROW AT NINE AM. BY THAT.